i believe so
oh the recording has started
okay
i call the meeting of the public works
and highways committee to order
as the chair of the house public works
and highways committee i find that due
to the state of emergency declared by
the governor as a result of the covet 19
pandemic in accordance with house rule
67 and the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
2020.04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
these are presentations pertaining to
the capital budget
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am affirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen and
if necessary participate in this meeting
by the zoom platform
or by telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91-8
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should email
lba
underscore fiscal
fiscal
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting shall be
adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting assisting us christopher
shea and scott shannon both from the
legislative budget assist
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
let us start the meeting by taking roll
call attendance when each member states
their presence please also state whether
there is anyone in the room with you
during this meeting
required under the right to know law
mr clerk if you would call the role
please
thank you mr chair
representative graham
president at my home in bedford
uh i am alone
representative mills i am here alone i'm
sorry i'm
i'm at home my wife is downstairs
somewhere having breakfast
representative phadolfy
representative blasic
here my husband is upstairs working and
my two-year-old is here but soon my
babysitter will be here and then i will
be in a room alone
representative boards
i am here at home alone with my dog
representative thompson
i'm present in my office in colebrook
and i am alone
representative clutier uh present in my
claremont home uh my brother is in
another part of the house
representative edgar
uh president i'm here in hampton uh i'm
home alone right now
representative ebel
um
representative faulkner
i am home in swansea my wife isn't in
the other room
representative newman
yes home in nashua my husband's in the
other room
representative peterson
president at home alone in nashua
representative bunker
uh thank you mr chairman we have 14
members of public works and highways
committees present
uh did you get representative gadhafi
also
on
did i hear somebody say representative
philadelphia is here
yes he
is thank you one two three four
thank you thank you representative
philadelphia mr chair we have 16 members
thank you mr clerk before i we begin our
first presentation i have a couple of
quick announcements
um there is an additional presentation
at the end
of the dot presentation later this
morning
it is from ports and harbors about a
problem that has arisen
um over there and so we will listen to
uh
gino marconi um explain what the problem
is
several of you have asked me why you all
got a a zoom link to
the lapse extension meeting it is
because i asked um
that the link be sent out to all
committee members in case
you did want to join even though you had
not said that
you wanted to be part of the
subcommittee
however it's always been open to any
member of the committee when we were
doing it in person and i wanted to
extend that courtesy to everyone you do
not have to participate if you do not
want to
on march 16th
there will be the public hearing on
house bill 25
followed by another work session
um
and then this afternoon we will be
having a work session
to begin to look at the agency
presentations and what if anything we
are going to do with them
i intend to take some straw votes at
that
understanding the straw votes or just
that they can change after the public
hearing and before the executive session
but we need to get working on
at least the non-controversial
um
items at least i think are
non-controversial at the moment we shall
see
um
with that
um i ask that everybody remain remain
muted unless you are actually asking a
question
and at this time our first presentation
is from the university system
and the
i would like to welcome kathy provencher
chief administrative officer and vice
chancellor uh for for foreign not for
financial affairs excuse me welcome uh
mr venture
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee for for those of you that
i've known for some time it's very nice
to see you again and for those of you
that um i haven't had the opportunity to
meet
it's uh it's nice to meet you virtually
again for the record my name is
catherine provencher and i serve as the
chief administrative officer and vice
chancellor for finance for the
university system bill janelle the
associate vice president for facilities
and operations at unh is with me this
morning as is matt purcell the director
of capital planning for the university
system
i believe you've been provided our
presentation in advance we are not going
to walk through all these slides we want
to make sure there's there's time for
questions
and
also
included in that we included an appendix
on the
health sciences simulation center that's
a project that was funded with state
operating appropriations in the last
biennium not in the capital budget it is
a capital project and we provide that
for your information
i if it's okay i'm going to share my
screen
so for um for those that were
here in 2019 you'll recall that
a three biennium appropriation was made
in house bill 25 in 2019 for the
university system
and that over those three biennium that
funded three capital projects partially
funded three capital projects
one on each of our residential campuses
and in house bill 25
in the current legislative session
that continues the 2020 22 23
appropriation of 15 million dollars
was uh is included and we would ask that
no change be made to that continuing
appropriation that's in house bill 25
there is a lapse extension in section
of house bill 25 and i have already made
the lba office aware that
that lap extension can be removed the
university system has already expended
the 10 million dollars that was
appropriated in the current biennium
from the
so this is our uh capital budget request
that was submitted as part of the agency
and governor's phase
for fiscal 22 and 23 again
this aligns with what was presented and
adopted back in 2019 and is what is
included in house bill 25 this session
15 million dollars
for the biological sciences initiative
which you're going to hear a lot more
about shortly uh bill janelle will that
will provide
quite a bit of detail on that project
it's the largest project ever undertaken
by the university system
there's also two and a half million
dollars
each um
allocated to plymouth state university
and keene state university for excuse me
keene state college
for academic buildings um
in in real need of upgrade and um
deferred maintenance
and again that will partially be funded
through state appropriations hopefully
and um as well as university system
dollars
as is required by state law we provide a
six-year
capital plan if you will and so for
fiscal 26 and 27
these amounts obviously are not in-house
bill 25 but we have added this
smith nesmith health sciences
out in 26 and 27 our college of health
and human services at unh
is
over capacity we have been successful in
recruiting
many additional students so that that's
a number of years out but that's on the
horizon
so um
covered 19 has significantly impacted
higher ed just as it has impacted just
about every industry in the state and
people
we do know that higher ed education
is going to be significantly transformed
in the coming years because of covet 19
notwithstanding that transformation
these projects that are included in
house bill 25
remain critically important
to the university system and
i wanted to give you an overview of our
entire capital program at the university
system
we provide a six-year look again in
alignment with with the six-year
requirement in state law
but our capital funding sources
primarily i mean the vast majority come
from university system funds
a portion comes from new debt the
university system does not have
authority to issue debt
related to academic structures
which is why we
often seek state support for for
academic structures
we have not issued new debt since 2016
and have no plans
to do so in the near future and again
any bonds the university system issues
are for what we call self-supporting
structures those would include
residence halls dining halls and the
like
i also wanted to mention that you know
in a normal year not coveted in a normal
year our total capital program from
university system funds
is about 60 to 65 million dollars
and that is based on
our one-year depreciation we try to
invest at the level of depreciation to
keep up with our deferred maintenance
and we've been successful in doing that
for the current fiscal year and probably
out to 2023
we've had to pull back on that
normal capital program just for cash
preservation efforts
because of covid19
i will say though that the projects that
are included in the in house bill 25
are moving forward those were not pulled
back because of the importance of that
those those projects across the
university system
so
on this one
this 555 is from all sources to include
your own
that's right that's right so
um you'll see in the pie chart
393 million of the 550
55 came from
university system sources and then
came from bonds over these six years
five percent from gifts and grants and
20 million from state appropriations
thank you
i'm going to turn it over to
bill janelle we really want to spend
some time on this biological sciences
initiative it's a
really a transformative project for
um
not just unh but the state as a whole we
believe
so
bill i'm going to turn that over turn it
over to you and just let me know when
you need me to
uh
move slides forward
okay
thank you kathy uh good morning
representative graham members of the
committee uh nice to see uh many of you
again and nice to meet although be
virtually those members that i haven't
met in the past so i just want to give
you a high level overview of the
biological sciences initiative so kathy
so
just high-level funding summary over the
three bienniums that we're looking at so
22-23
state appropriation of 10 million is uh
going to support the ongoing
construction of the biological sciences
project as kathy stated previously
the committee's committed 35 million
over three biennia for the 95.5 million
project and that budget has increased
since the last time we've met and i'll
get into detail about that further in
the slides but just wanted to reiterate
that um
that increase
we see that as a responsibility of usnh
and we're not requesting anything
additional over what's been previously
uh approved
next slide please
so just a high overview so the project
budget 95.5 million our architect our
architect is ellis wag associates and
our construction manager is skanska
and the construction delivery method is
cm at risk
next slide kathy
um so just a high-level view of the
project so it's a two-phase project and
on the site plan view below here
uh you can see we've the first phase is
in addition which is shown in blue here
and the second phase is a gut renovation
of existing spalding hall which is a
1960s vintage science building
this top view that you see here is the
ground uh level floor plan
and just
that red dash line that goes through the
middle delineation delineates the
difference between phase one the
addition in phase two uh the existing
building
so just quickly running through the
schedule we completed our utility work
in the summer of 2019
finalized our construction documents for
both phases in fall of 19 and we signed
our guaranteed maximum price for phase
one in december of that same year
uh phase one construction
is currently underway
and that's on schedule and we see
completion of that in about a year in
april of 22.
we recently signed our guaranteed
maximum price for phase two in january
of this year
and phase two construction will start
january of 22 there is some overlap
there between the phases but the
majority in january of 22 with
completion of the project in april of
24.
next slide please kathy
uh so again it's a 95.5 million dollar
project it includes a 50 000 square foot
addition that's phase one along with a
gut renovation of uh existing spalding
hall which is about 82 000 square feet
um and it'll do a lot of things for us
and these are you know four of the the
important things it'll do number one
it'll address significant deferred
maintenance in spaulding hall like i
said it's an it's a
1960s vintage science building
it looks like one and uh we've certainly
done all we can to hold it together over
recent years to keep things going but
this is uh much needed much welcomed
work to that building to upgrade those
mechanical systems and keep the building
operational and improve the building
significantly
uh so it will also increase capacity for
enrollments in in these high-end science
fields or high-demand science fields
that we're seeing
it'll upgrade our laboratory and
teaching spaces
uh that again look like 1960 spaces in
in many of
those labs in spaulding hall and the
ultimate goal is we're going to increase
graduates which then will increase our
workforce supply for the many businesses
that are looking for these folks and to
put them to work and hopefully improve
the state's economy along the way
uh next slide please kathy
so the completed project it'll have 11
biological science teaching labs nine
research lab suites and we'll be able to
accommodate an additional 50 principal
researchers
um one of the
the
components of the project is to
construct a new vivarium our current
vibram is in coney hall which is one of
our oldest
buildings on campus and again it's um
it's the significant deferred
maintenance there it's outlived its
useful life but this uh the vivarium
it's a it's a place where research
animals are housed and
isolated and a place where they can be
studied and it's necessary for all the
research work that occurs in this
building so it's a critical component uh
that's that will be added as part of
this project
again the addition will be completed in
april of 22
and by the end of may the the existing
building would be vacated and those
folks would move into the additional the
addition the addition space uh not all
will fit in that space we're also
relocating folks throughout campus
um
but then we would move forward go into
existing spaulding hall do that
renovation
with a goal of completing by december of
23 and then the last phase of the
project is to fit out that vibrarium
which would be completed by april of 24.
next slide please kathy
okay so the budget um so the last time
we came and met
we had a budget of 86 million dollars
that has since increased to 95.5 so
we're seeing a 9.5 million dollar budget
increase again that's the res that
additional increase is the
responsibility of usnh but these are
some of the reasons for the increase
one being project complexity this is a
very complex project as you can imagine
um
many science labs we're renovating an
existing building we've got freshwater
lab marine labs um
mechanical systems are very complex as
well and at the time in june in 2018
when we had put together that original
budget we didn't have our construction
manager on board
so all of those details of how
everything would fit together weren't
completely nailed down
the scope of the project really hasn't
changed but the complexity we have a
better handle on what that complexity is
so that was one uh driver of that
increased cost
we've also seen uh increased costs from
our subcontractors this construction
market that we're working in is um the
most
the hottest or the most active that
we've seen i've seen certainly in my
career
in in these areas we've not seen a dip
as a result of cobid uh still high
demand for subcontractors that are out
there
and as a result we've seen it
we've seen
additional prices over what we had
anticipated for things like
building automation controls lab case
work electrical work
those areas
saw some increase as well
delays
when covet hit last year
we needed to slow things down a little
bit from a cash flow standpoint to get
our arms around this project
and also other expenses throughout the
university so that contributed when when
things take longer things cost more
unfortunately that contributed somewhat
to this cost increase and also cobit did
as well so additional protocols
for testing some uh
results and delays and material
availability
um and and scheduling so that
contributed to that cost as well
next next slide please kathy so the good
news is it's been a great winter to work
we've made some great progress on the
project
the exterior of the building is complete
and we're now working inside on our
mechanical systems and coordinating all
of that work to pull the building
together
so next slide please kathy
this is a slide a picture on the inside
just showing some of the work that's
ongoing
um
part of the challenge like i mentioned
before is once we complete the addition
we're going to then need to relocate
folks into that so there's a significant
um
movement of people or moving of people
that needs to happen that'll happen
within the addition but it'll also
happen across campus so there's many
other spaces that we're looking to fit
out in order to keep operations going i
know you folks deal a lot with highways
and bridges building a building is in
many ways is not that much different in
that we need to keep the operation going
and keep and sometimes need to build a
new space in order to move all the folks
into it in order to complete uh renovate
the old space so that's part of what's
going on now but we're making great
progress and uh on schedule to finish
this project up
so next slide please get so
that's
that's what i've got
thanks bill and
the the keane and plymouth projects we
provided you information in the advanced
materials
uh honestly they they haven't changed
since two years ago they are needed
projects they are um
hyde halls in the planning stage right
now at plymouth
and uh we continue to believe that those
are critically important projects for
for keene and plymouth and we're happy
representative jack
thank you mr chairman uh it's lovely to
see all of our old friends from the unh
i was going to ask you about your laps
extension
but you answered that already your laps
of 187 is noted
thank you mr chair uh and this might be
a moot point it might just be my lack of
complete paperwork here
but um i noticed on the capital budget
repair
compare report that we've got from the
lba that there's only one line item
listed which is the biological sciences
initiative and it's for the entire 15
million
so i wanted to be make sure that i
understand that only 10 million of this
is going to the biological uh services
initiative and the other five is split
between these other two renovations
that's right i believe and lba might be
able to help me on this i believe the
language
in back excuse me back in 2019
and currently has one line item for 15
million dollars but lists the three
projects
and so the university system has
um allocated those projects ten ten two
and a half and two and a half
chris do i have that right
you do kathy and that's my um shorthand
in that worksheet i just put the
biological center because it was the
biggest piece and left it at that
okay thank you very much
you're welcome
representing mcconkey you have your hand
up
all right moving on um
uh rep sharon graham yeah chairman do
you happy now get you now
okay thank you sorry
things are a little hectic here in
freedom uh chancellor uh nice to see you
and um i was a few minutes late checking
on
uh speaking on the biological uh
uh center that uh
you're promoting here of great interest
a couple things caught my ai
talked about uh how important this was
to the new hampshire workforce
um and um so
i two-part question so
are um
are you working collaboratively with any
industries
um here that are specifically looking
for activities and are also going to
help with some of your labs if it's if
it's specialty
bill you want to take that
uh well we've certainly had much
interest from companies throughout the
state i mean the one that uh and i
believe
we had a previous presentation that
listed all those companies the one that
comes to mind is lonza that's right down
the road that has been very interested
in this project and um actually came to
um
public works some a number of years ago
with us to help support the project when
it was initially being presented um so a
lot of interest in in
local companies and they're they're
looking to get our graduates to put them
to work for sure as far as direct
financial
contributions
i don't see that yet as part of this
project but typically there are um that
does occur as the project moves forward
so i'm sorry i don't have exact
information on that but i i anticipate
there would be some of that coming
okay
and for the chancellor thank you for
that
um life is life is going to be different
if if i could
um mr chairman uh life life is different
with covid
and i i see
at my age a lot of this is going to
carry forward is your business model
adapting to that
um are you
or do you still see that you need
large facilities large labs large
classrooms
so so the business model is absolutely
changing
and
we are adapting i would say in the area
of labs
we're still going to need labs that's
the
one that is one of the types of
education that we're going to have to
have hands-on instruction
we do have
plans underway across the university
system on rethinking
space
um
on uh and sharing class classes if you
will
there's a pilot program going on for the
fall where we could have
plymouth students taking a course
with technology at unh for example
but but in the area of of labs i don't
representative evil
thank you very much mr chair and nice to
see our friends from unh
aside from the whittemore center and
other places like that
thanks for helping us out with those
things um
so actually it's a little bit it's it
sort of follows on to what uh
representative mcconkey said um you read
a lot about demographics and decreasing
uh student populations and things of
that nature and
when you're looking forward at your
business model capital projects things
like that how do you see the future
working out thank you thank you for the
question and likewise good to see you
representative evil the um
yes we are
laser focused on what's what's coming uh
demographics by 2025
tell us that um
the the number of high school students
will drop more than 15 percent from
where it is now
there are lots of other pressures on
the business model of higher education
so
um you know as a rule
we're not building more square feet
as a matter of fact we have plans at
keene
to
demolish some res halls that are
need needing a lot of deferred
maintenance and we don't see the
population
of students going back to what it was 10
years ago
so we are adapting that that um
you know we're pivoting wherever
possible and not just on the capital
program on
on all kinds of fronts on administrative
financial academic programs because
we have been focused on what not just
the demographics but our students
have a lot more need putting more
pressure on our finances
so um
i'm i'm actually up to my eyeballs on
please send me yeah turn on my mic good
morning chancellor um
correct me if i'm wrong but in the
beginning we had uh
mr janelle telling us that
it took you some time to get the
construction manager on board
and there uh if i
heard him correctly and this is not the
term he used but
their contract is not to exceed contract
is that not to exceed contract on the
entire cost of the project or on their
services
yes
um
the guaranteed maximum price that i
talked about is on the entire contract
so that's we had we signed a guaranteed
maximum price for
phase one and phase two which includes
the construction manager cost and all
the subcontractor costs as well that we
were bid independently
follow
please
let me get unmuted yes
um
mr janelle uh
so we should anticipate no additional
requests
between now and the completion of this
project
and that's our yes that is our plan this
is the budget for the project and we do
not see any increases beyond what's
proposed right now this is a guaranteed
maximum price and we plan to live within
that budget
okay thank you very much
and
for the new members
this has been
an ongoing project in the way we've
helped fund some capital projects at the
university system
and that we provide certain amount of
money for the project and if it comes in
over what the estimate is
the university system picks up that
additional cost
rather than coming back to the state for
additional
uh monies so it's been a good uh
relationship for the last 20 years that
we've been doing this
and so
um i'm glad to see that they are
continuing with picking up that
i see no other hands uh vice chancellor
i do have a question we haven't gone to
it about the simulation center
but for many of us we were taken by
surprise
two years ago in the operating budget
where a capital project
was introduced to be funded with
operating funds
are there any of those types of
surprises in this current budget
no absolutely not the operating
appropriation for the university system
has been reduced five percent over our
current block grant so no there are no
one-time dollars in the operating budget
in in house bill 1.
thank you i
i just wanted to say i'm building a
house and i really feel your pain on
increasing construction costs um
sorry to ask this question but i um
i'd love to hear any comments you care
to make on the prospective merger that's
being proposed between your system and
the community college system
so um
our board is fully supportive of a um
a proposal to to
create a new board to oversee
what what are currently two systems and
and part of that
i would say most of that representative
evil goes back to your
your uh earlier question
that we have been
studying
and um hearing from experts
on on what's coming
for higher ed and covid
has exacerbated it
that there is going to be a real
transformation of higher education
and um
that that we can
you know have a a
a new kind of public higher education
system for the granite state
by the time that that uh cliff that
demographic cliff hits us that uh it's
important to make a bold move
there are a lot of unanswered questions
we we certainly recognize that
but but we are supportive of the
proposal
any other questions
um on this portion of the presentation
it's nice that they are not asking for
additional funds because there aren't
many
um
as the former treasurer could
attest it's always a challenge
to stay within what the treasurer
recommends
but since we do have a little bit of
time
vice chancellor if you could just
briefly hit the simulation center so
that we know
what is being built out there even
though it's not not
capital appropriations it is a capital
project
sure and and um actually
knee-deep in this so he can probably
provide you with a
better overview of the project i can
tell you that
the purpose of this was to be able to
support
nursing and other
health sciences programs we just did not
have the capacity
to accept additional nurses nursing
students and it's been successful we we
uh
we have really grown the program so bill
do you want to
provide them with uh provide the
committee with overview sure
sure glad to
uh so yes our health science simulation
center
um so project budget of nine million
uh again operating funds through fy 2021
our architect lavalier brensinger
uh construction manager is right ryan
and this is a design build project
that's the delivery method that we have
forward
next slide please
uh so it'll create 21 000 square feet of
instructional space in core campus it's
just it's just west of the railroad
track so i'll show a slide of that going
forward but it's just an interior uh
rendering of uh some gathering space in
the project itself
next slide please
so here's uh aerial view kind of giving
you a sense of where it is uh the
railroad tracks are kind of at the top
right corner
of the slide uh greg hall is kind of
uh at the bottom of the slide
um it's a it's a low-cost light
commercial building very fast track
um we're looking to have this project
done by august so that it can be
occupied in the fall of this year
and as kathy said it supports our health
our college of health and human services
particularly nursing other health
education programs and one of the
big one one of the things we're trying
to achieve here is to create this
simulation space
where
nursing students one of the big
challenges with putting a nursing
student through our program
is finding them placement in hospitals
and other care centers where they can
have their practical experience
by creating a simulation center some of
that experience can be done
here in the simulation center itself so
that allows us to increase that capacity
of graduates that we can get through
this is a really high demand uh
major within unh or majors within within
chhs
next slide please kathy and this is just
an interior rendering of some of that
simulation space so they have mannequins
very lifelike that they can do uh some
of their
practical work
here instead of going out uh
to to hospitals they'd still have to do
that but part of it can be accomplished
here
um so again looking to get this
completed by fall um it's
i actually i can look out the window and
see the building right now it's taking
shape very well and they're on on the
inside uh starting some of the uh
mechanical work and finishes to move
forward
next slide please
oh and that's it
um thank you for that um vice chancellor
um this looks like a great addition to
your health sciences project are there
any ongoing discussions with the
community college system
about utilizing this space for some of
their nursing programs or affiliated
i'm not aware of any
we do have
that's not to say that
that that won't happen
we have a um
actually we've been meeting since the
fall maybe late summer we have a a
synergies group if you will it's a task
force made up of
some um college presidents from the
university system college presidents
from community college i'm on that we
have a couple of trustees
we meet bi-weekly we've identified a
number of synergies we've already
started working on with with contracts
and academic programs
so i believe that you know that that's
um
something that that we could be looking
at in the future
i i would appreciate that because it
goes to the the core of what
representative ebal and others have been
asking about going forward and how we're
going to
work the two systems together
even if we do not merge them in the
fashion the governor may be envisioning
but it's still going to be critical
moving forward
thank you mr chairman um
i wanted to ask a question about the
fyes 26 and 27. do you mind if we get
into that if we have a little time would
you rather talk about something else
we've got a little bit of time but
you know we can talk about it but we
can't find any future legislature
about funding
or or even
um
yeah you can ask
thank you um i see in the uh the
schedule you have you're showing
for the new hampshire of the nesmith
health services uh out in that 26 27
area about 12 million
uh that you might want to try to get out
of the state and 18 for yourselves
um
bill you want to take that
sure um i mean we're still in the
preliminary stages but again chhs is
probably our fastest growing college on
campus and it related to health sciences
and all the need that's out there
so
they have identified additional space
beyond the simulation center that we're
building right now this is to address
immediate needs in growth that we're
seeing in the nursing program for those
similar for that simulation uh
experience but uh this project looks at
nezmuth hall which again is one of our
oldest halls on campus
um is in need of uh
a lot of attention there's a lot of
deferred maintenance there so we're
doing a study right now to look at how
we could
provide that additional space to chhhs
and within nezmuth while at the same
time addressing a lot of our uh deferred
maintenance needs in that building as
well so don't have a lot of the details
as to how it would all actually come
together right now but where i i should
have that study hopefully within a month
or so to
better outline that and we'll have more
coming forward for sure but it's it's
basically um chhs is expanding very
quickly we're trying to do all we can to
accommodate that growth within existing
spaces on campus that need attention
anyway repurposing those um older
buildings that are you know
core to unh campus and and better
and to follow up on that in relation to
representative ebel's
earlier question
we are not about um
expanding our footprint rather take a
building in core campus that is in need
of rehab and repurpose that space
if i could follow up chairman quick
go ahead
thank you um so i guess you'll with this
consideration of the combining some of
the
community college uh programs that that
would be to take into consideration as
far as instead of expanding something
else but i guess you didn't say
expanding but i assume that you'll be
considering
the needs of the community colleges
along those lines which seems to be
great
absolutely if this if
if this proposal moves forward that will
be part of a comp i would
believe part of a comprehensive view of
the needs across
all of the the institutions
thank you
i see
no other hands just for the committee's
edification
even though this 15 million dollars was
promised in the last biennium it does
count against the general funded portion
of the capital budget this biannual so
we don't have 15 million dollars to play
with it it is there and the treasurer
does count it as part of the
her recommendation ceiling
um so if you look at the
spreadsheet sent out by the lba
um it is included in the general fund
portion of the budget so
don't think just because we had promised
it before it had already been accounted
for
isn't that right uh vice chancellor
yes that's right representative you're
i owe that explanation to the lba
actually
we very much appreciate um your time
this morning and as always if there are
any follow-up questions or additional
information that would be helpful to you
in in your decision making uh by all
means um you know chris and i are in
contact and we're happy to get you any
follow-up information if that would be
helpful
and we thank you for coming and we thank
you for your presentation
um
and if any of the members have questions
of you or your staff you have provided
your contact information so
i would ask that they they query you
directly before we go to exact session
on house bill 25 and thank you for
coming
thanks very much
thank you enjoy your day
we will um
i have 10 19
or on my computer anyways and our next
presentation is not until
10 30 which is the department of
transportation
so
we are in recess
until 10 30.
thank you
i'm trying to see if he's saying
something but i don't think
yes i can
um i've got a constituent in my office
i'm dealing with an issue here so i'm
gonna have to sit out for five or ten
minutes is that all right
oh it's fine um
we will be hearing from d.o.t join us
hello representative philadelphia yes
i've got a doctor's appointment in
concord at two o'clock
i'll have to leave by one
okay
um
we will miss you this afternoon then but
um we'll we will just be discussing some
of the more
non-controversial
agencies
essentially the ones who did not ask for
additional funding
well you know we need to get our work
done there aren't many of those yeah
you've been here before jim yes i have
when is it when we're going to start
having executive sessions
it will probably be
somewhere
either the 20 somewhere around the 25th
but that will be in the calendar
our public hearing will be on the 16th
and then the following week we'll do
some work and exact session
and try to get it done because we have
to have it done by the first of april
okay
thanks
there's also getting the committee
amendment drafted
well that's that that's the piece there
and we can't do that until we know what
all right the
time being
10 30. um our next presentation on the
capital budget
is from the department of transportation
and i see that the commissioner has
already brought forward welcome
commissioner
as always to public works and highways
and i believe you have members several
members of your staff with you
correct good morning mr chairman members
of the committee um
thank you for this opportunity to
present our capital budget requests
we do have several of the dot team
participating this morning and so chris
was chuck the deputy commissioner will
actually walk you through the majority
of our capital budget presentation
and then available for questions we have
bill cass our assistant commissioner
as well as marie mullen our director of
finance
so i think marie would you mind sharing
your screen
please do so okay
um so in preparation for today uh we did
produce one of our standard uh budget
books um for those of you that are
returning to the committee and you'll
recall that we
typically put together
a capital budget book for the governor's
phase of uh the process and so we did
send you
a lengthy document i think it was 74
pages which includes a lot of
photographs and um
you know long descriptions of each of
our projects for the purposes of today
as we would when we meet in person
we won't be going through every page of
that document instead we will highlight
certain pages
but we thought it was helpful to give
the committee all of that background on
the various projects
we're going to start with our general
fund requests and we have three projects
that would be supported with general
funds
then we have five projects that were
supported uh by the governor um as part
of our highway fund request
and then um marie mullen has been
working closely with chris shea from lba
and so we're actually going to talk
about some of our additional additional
needs for prior capital budget items i
know we're coming back later in the week
to talk about lapse extensions um but
chris thought it was important for us to
touch on
um some of the cost increases associated
with past hb 25 projects
and then lastly we'll run through some
of the additional needs that were not
supported and i'm just seeing that
patrick harlechi our director of
aeronautics rail and transit is also
joining us should you have any questions
on the general fund items that we're
going to touch on first
um so that's the format for today um
like i said most of the presentation
materials are in the longer booklet that
we sent you and marie did send a copy of
this more abbreviated presentation to
chris for distribution this morning
um so with that i'm going to ask uh
chris wasschuck to
walk you through the presentation um
and you know we're happy mr chairman to
either take questions as we go or go
through the presentation and take
questions at the end whatever is most
appropriate
why don't we take questions
at the end of the general funded portion
and then we'll see how how it's going on
on the rest probably at the break of
what is in the
governor's proposal and then after your
suggestions on
prior appropriations and then we'll talk
take a take questions and then your your
additional requests and take questions
at that kind of break it up into the
pieces that you
you have laid out so that we get the
questions answered right then rather
than all at the end that sounds good at
the end of each section we'll pause and
and take your questions and i also
spotted kathy is on as well our liaison
to this committee um so should you have
any questions after today as usual you
know kathy's a great resource in terms
of reaching out and getting the answers
that you need so with that i'll turn it
over to chris who'll
start with the general fund portion
so thank you commissioner and good
morning mr chairman and members of the
committee
um just for the record my name is chris
wasschuck deputy commissioner with the
department so i am going to go through
these slides fairly quickly um and
mr chair as you noted we'll pause after
each section for any questions so this
is kind of the overview these are three
uh projects that
have been approved by the governor um
and there were three projects that we
submitted as part of our capital budget
requests in essence they total 1.72
million in general funds
and it leverages actually there's only
27 million shown there but it leverages
uh quite a bit more of federal funds
um and we'll talk about that in in a
moment um but the three projects in
essence are um for
um
five percent match for the faa program
um a 10 match for
the public transit
bus capital program and
funding for a new aircraft registration
software system
so
marie if you can go to the next slide
in essence and we've put this
we send the sheet out to all the
directors to fill in information
um
so in essence um the first priority um
first general funded priority is um is
for 1.2 million of general funds to
leverage
27.7 million of federal funds and it
really is to support the continued
safety improvements and development of
airports uh within the state by
providing that five percent uh of the
required ten percent match for the faa
program which in essence involves the
airport improvement projects
uh the ratio of funds feature um for
each of the uh projects is based on
ninety percent federal funding a five
percent state share which
in this case will be this general funded
capital budget request and a five
percent local share
um
in essence the funds for these projects
will be used you know for for federally
eligible airports from manchester all
the way to uh to berlin i believe there
are 12
federally eligible airports
the request will include approximately
airport improvement projects
for planning and infrastructure
improvements at those 12
public use airports
and also it will include improvements to
the new hampshire aircraft registration
excuse me aircraft rescue and
firefighting training facility which is
located in concord
you know typical
involve runway rehabilitation
you know taxiway uh
apron uh rehabilitation airport uh
airport obstruction removal and lighting
land acquisition easement acquisition
and so on so those are kind of the
typical projects that are included with
this request
this is
a request
for
uh 251
and 250 of general funds as a match to
leverage 2.5 million of federal uh
transit funds from fta
these federal funds you know provide at
least eighty percent of the capital
needs for eligible transit capital
projects and this requested capital uh
excuse me uh capital match will provide
um no more than 10
or half of the required match it's an 80
20 program
and the remaining 10
will be local funds
um
so state participation enables transit
providers to leverage federal capital
funds for needed vehicle replacements
and facility improvements that might not
otherwise be available and completed
in essence the state
federal and local funds will provide the
ability to replace approximately 25
vehicles
um from the non-profit agencies that
provide transportation for our seniors
and individuals with disabilities and
also provide the ability to acquire some
intermodal infrastructure that may be
included such as bicycle pedestrian
infrastructure
um
which
typically a bike rack passenger shelters
um wayfair signage and so on
you know so in essence again this 251
250 of general funds
will leverage um and match 2.5 million
of federal transit funds
and um we have just a couple photos here
showing uh what the typical vehicle that
is replaced
with these with these funds you can see
the vehicle is
quite quite aged and um and quite
this is the third um
priority um that is funded with general
funds
and it requests 300 000 for the
replacement of the department's aircraft
registration program
in essence um the existing registration
system was developed back in 2001 and
implemented in 2003 so it's
just about 20 years old
it is archaic
and really needs to be replaced
what the aviation registration program
does is it collects revenue for the
state to support airports and aviation
programs in the state it also the
registration also provides additional
benefits to department
such as data collection
that is done as part of the registration
process is used by the department for
various regulatory needs and compliance
uh needs and
successfully planned for airport
development programs
so during the as you may know during the
2018 legislative session senate bill 565
was passed and signed by the governor
which changed the methodology to
register
aircraft in the state this legislation
changed the fee methodology to a
weight-based uh rate structure with
associated fees
in in an effort to attract more aircraft
to businesses to the state this change
reduced the aircraft their registration
fees from approximately 1 million to 400
000.
you know so in essence um what happens
is up to 400 000 250 000 are provided to
airports based on formula
uh where the aircraft is based and the
remaining revenue is deposited into
general fund which is approximately 150
000 of the 400.
due to the useful life of the current
software um in this legislative change
a new system is really needed
and this system will be web-based and
allow
payments to be made by credit cards
as well as to be more interactive and
useful by the public
so
again this is for three hundred thousand
dollar general funded
request
to replace the existing aircraft
registration
and with that those are the three
general fund funded items so i'll pause
here for any questions
the committee may have
representative jack
mr chairman uh thank you
everyone uh
benefit of the new do you think it would
be worth high low that uh the aaa is who
decides what airport projects are being
done and has taken the five percent
match we don't really have anything to
and you're correct um based on faa's
changing priorities um they may
the the projects um may change
um but
we do have
you know based on the common priorities
and patrick hurley he may be able to
answer this a little better but based on
the current priorities we anticipate um
what those projects are and the level of
funding needed and that's that's how the
patrick do you have anything to add
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is
patrick curlahie i'm the director of
aeronautics rail and transit at d.o.t
um yeah um the way the faa aip program
works we are heavily we rely heavily on
discretionary funding
so that's why the faa has has a great
say in what the priority for the
projects are what we do is we go with
each of the federally eligible airports
we go through a capital improvement
planning process for a five-year period
then we sit down with faa and look at
what faa is going to
believes will be the priorities in the
coming years uh for the types of
projects whether they be runway
rehabilitation projects taxiways
obstruction
uh removal
and then uh try to to work with it with
the capital improvement programs and
come up with uh the list that then we
send to faa for their review
and scoring and and then their
determination on what projects will get
funded so
we do have a say we do
we do um meet with faa we advocate for
the projects that are in each of the
airports capital improvement plans and
they certainly take that into
consideration
representative abbott
thank you mr chairman i just wanted to
ask the standard question
with this software as the dit been
involved in
um
yes representative we're very fortunate
we have
doit staff embedded at dut
and they support both our current
registration software and will also be
involved in implementation of any new
software
thank you
thank you mr chairman on
point number four there nice to see all
d.o.t without saying
um on um where talked about the change
in legislation from 2018
to the weight-based rate structure did
that result in
more income
more registrations i guess i'm saying
for planes aircraft
i can answer that question um
thank you for the question
representative mcconkey it's still a
little too early to tell we've only been
doing this now for a year and a half the
20 2018
legislation took place in in happy we do
a calendar year registration but the
change didn't take effect until until
july first of that year
um so we're still looking at that we've
had an uptick actually in smaller planes
in experimental planes versus
the heavy the heavier planes
the the uh revenue from that is still
down to about five um
about four hundred thousand dollars
a year four hundred to five hundred
thousand dollars a year where prior to
the change we were receiving
approximately a million dollars a year
so but i still think it's still a little
too early to to tell uh if it's been
that's if it's been successful or not
thank you patrick thank you mr chairman
you're welcome
see no no other hands i do have one
question
on the the transit bus
um
where it comfort 10 match
i believe you were talking about a match
for 2.5 million
is it safe to
talk about that as as leveraging 2.5 or
is it just in the hopes that there will
i think it's actually 5 million
um because it's half the
is is used for that um
i think but
my math is not my starting point so um
but yes this is funding that's in
that that we anticipate we anticipate
level funding even though the fast act
authorization
lasts for only a year we are we're
anticipating that we will receive at
least level funding uh through that
program right i would also
um like to add that this is a lot less
than what we usually ask for in this
category we've been up to almost a
million dollars before in this
uh that's uh if if we if we're granted
the lapse extensions we sh we have
enough funding to fund all of the public
transit vehicles the fixed route transit
vehicles in the next biennium this is
mostly for
human service agencies that provide
transportation for seniors and and
those with disabilities and also some
infrastructure that would be done for
the public transit system the
infrastructure would be but a majority
of this is is for vehicles for the that
service the elderly and disabled
the reason i ask is sometimes it is
easier to sell things
to members of the general court if you
can say that this is in there to
leverage
x amount of federal funds
rather than just a standalone
appropriation that
doesn't look like it's leveraging much
and i think we did that in the actual
project justification in the form that
went to the capitol for
uh for this capital budget item it talks
about that the reason it's not in the
cas
it
the federal funding for this particular
item is in the actually in the operating
budget
and not like in aeronautics where it's
in the capital budget
so the you would see the federal funding
in in class 72 in the operating budget
oh another one of those fun things yeah
okay thank you i just wanted to make
sure that that when we say something
that
we we are selling it correctly
yeah so if i may mr chairman you know as
patrick said the fast act the current
federal authorization does expire in
september
um we are extremely optimistic that in
this area we'll get at least
the same funding if not more
so i think it's safe to say that you
truly are leveraging our federal dollars
thank you
see no other questions on this section
so in essence uh
this this
chart shows um
that the department submitted 10
10 priority items to be
bonded and and that service funded with
highway funds
that totaled
what what the governor approved were the
top five priorities
um and they totaled 14.8 million
um
in essence the the biggest um
differences between
us our requests and the governance
approved um
items
were an additional 500 000 dollars for
statewide construction of salt sheds
and nearly doubling
of the estimate for the londonderry
patrol shed replacement and i'll talk
about that um when we get to the
individual items
so in essence the first highway funded
uh
priority um on the highway side
was for 1.7 million
and this is this is the government
approved dollar figure
for the statewide replacement of of salt
sheds
in essence
um the department cannot
currently store seasons worth of salt at
each patrol shed location and some of
the sheds really have reached their
useful life
they require significant maintenance um
or they're very very you know in very
very poor condition
um the ability to store ample salt um in
one season will save funds by by by
being able to
purchase that that salt and store under
um
under that facility um when the best
price is available and also there are
environmental regulations that require
that all salt be stored under cover
the apartment uses a typical high arch
gambrell design which allows delivery of
the salt to generally occur within the
shed
due to that high door opening and it
limits you know any kind of
environmental impacts in the area
um
this project will construct you know new
standalone salt buildings at different
locations throughout the state you know
based on a priority um at the bottom of
the page
you know the different um locations are
listed for example north hampton is a
shed that's 32 years old it's under
capacity and really structurally
deficient
you know a second one lincoln it's 37
years old and has the same issues uh
that one there we can have a current
capacity of 1650 tons
and what's used at that location is over
you know over 4 300 tons so um those are
the type of
facilities that we replace kind of in a
prior priority order based on the
available funding um that is allocated
so next slide marie
you know in essence um and this was this
was based on information last um
last fall
but recent you know based on that at
that time construction costs were
showing that we really needed to use
about 120 dollars per square foot uh to
construct that kind of building um
public works is telling us that is
probably about 20 percent higher today
um so based on the numbers above you
know we estimate that
locations would cost roughly around 400
to 450 000 upwards of to a million
dollars based on size and location
um
next slide marie
and these are just some photos i
mentioned northampton and lincoln so for
example this one here is a photo of
northampton you can see that it's um
it's very old in some cases it's leaning
um and
uh the structural stability is you know
really at risk here uh next next sheet
this is another um you know showing some
of the deterioration in post rod at
northampton and the one below is the
site at lincoln you know again you know
showing the undersized nature um and um
i don't know if you can make it out but
and we had a few more slides sent with
the original book teacher the committee
members that kind of give examples of
the conditions of the sheds that
we feel need to be replaced
priority i am the second highway funded
priority item is for 5 million for the
replacement of the current fuel
management system
as you know
the dot's fuel distribution system is
the strategic fuel reserve for all of
new hampshire state government
the fuel district
distribution system is uh computerized
um it's a fuel management system fmis
we call it it was originally
supplied by opec which is now
gas boy in essence and it's slated to
sunset
by that company in the next few years
the the sunset date is 2022 um and
coincidentally
the coming contract with
gas boy also ends
in june of 2022.
at that time the system will no longer
be supported you know any of the
software and hardware um at the 90 plus
fuel sites that that we have throughout
the state
the fuel distribution system normally
sees about four and a half to five
million gallons of throughput per year
and really requires a stable system to
manage and maintain those volumes any
disruption will certainly be
programmatic
uh problem problematic sorry
um this is a proprietary system um and
we will be hard pressed to deal with any
issues
that crop up or any major breakdowns
with a system we don't own the software
we own the data
you know so in essence what this system
will do um we are intending what this
request will do
is secure services to provide and
install a new new fuel management system
that will include all the hardware
operating system database
and
fuel management software
the vendor
will be responsible for all aspects of
the project
including but not limiting
limited to the design development
installation implementation testing
training and so on of the entire system
we
we have received proposals and we'll
talk about this
in a later section but we feel that this
item can be reduced down to the four
million dollar level um we've requested
five million and again we feel it can be
reduced down to the four million dollar
level
so this is the third priority it's the
lancaster storage building replacement
um it is for 595 000 to replace
this this storage building the existing
building is a wooden building
it's used for cold storage of materials
and some equipment
and this building has been in kind of a
deteriorated state for the last number
of years with main uh with repairs being
done at different times
one of the sidewalls of the building is
in very poor condition uh foundation
slab is broken several sections and
heaves which jams the sliding doors as
you can imagine is very problematic in
the wintertime and the roof has been
repaired several times because of its
leaks
this project replaces to remove the
existing
50 by 35 foot wooden structure and
replace it with a new 30 by 60 foot
steel building on a concrete slab
next
three pages kind of show
the building
[Music]
the bottom picture shows the side wall i
don't i don't believe you you can really
tell that's in poor shape but it is in
poor shape
um next few slides
uh show again the sidewall and some of
the some of the rut um that exists at
that building and then lastly this slide
kind of shows the concept we're going to
remove the existing building and put a
new pre-engineered a metal building up
in kind of the same location
or rotated 90 degrees
uh so the fourth highway funded priority
is this um
is
for 6.75 million for the replacement of
the londonderry patrol shed
what this also should state is it
includes the uh it includes a new salt
shed as well
i don't believe that was captured
when the original estimate was submitted
but this facility is undersized um
this facility services i-93 you know
with the expansion of i-93 from four to
eight lanes
um this facility is certainly not
capable in its current state of keeping
up with the the maintenance associated
with the increased lane miles of i-93
the facility also
does not meet modern building codes it's
so the new facility will be cited on the
on the same property
and also will have utility and computer
system upgrades are included
so the project will will construct a new
what we call right side right size
facility and it will include crew
quarters bathrooms foreman uh office and
vehicle storage bays for trucks right
now there's a five-person crew there
that are full-time with one temporary
person um for the winter and also we
have up to eight hired uh trucks with
operators
that
function out of that facility
the common facility is
too small to allow for the crew members
to take a break
it really only has one bathroom which is
inadequate for the crew size especially
in the winter when you have the added
higher trucks coming in and currently
the foreman uses a portion of the crew
quarters as an office which is really
not secure and conducive for employee
relations
also this facility's roof was leaking
we placed a rubber membrane over the
entire roof
as a temporary repair
in the winter there's only two plow
trucks that can be stored inside this
facility without any plow equipment
so the facility is scheduled to add an
another employee another truck
um
really with with these trucks they
really should be stored inside um to
prevent you know issues with um
with starting
as well as
you know emission controls
um when temperature is dropping below
freezing
the project will include an 80 by 100
foot building
that meets the common building codes
as well as utility hookups and as i
mentioned it will include a new salt
shed
so on the next page we have
and you can see the size of it
in the lower portion that will be
replaced
and again we had additional photos
included in the packet that was
submitted that i think provides a little
more description of the cramped quarters
of of this location
i do want to say and i probably didn't
not
mention that um
when we provided the initial estimate it
was based on
just the square footage of the new
facility
as public as the bureau of public works
took how to look at this location
they really increased
the cost based on the current climate
for public um public works type of
building construction
as well as additional utility costs
um and um
to account for the replacement of the
solid so that's why
the uh the cost has increased um
dramatically from i think our
request of roughly three three and a
half million to the governor's approved
and this is the fifth highway funded
priority that was approved by the
governor it's for 500 excuse me 800 000
um
you know in essence this is for
phase two of the work order system
that's currently underway
uh
i should say phase one is underway
um
in essence the state has invested tens
of billions of dollars in transportation
assets
in order to get uh the most out of this
major investment the department really
needs a modern and efficient means to
track future current and past
maintenance efforts for assets such as
bridges culverts guardrail and so on
um
in essence this phase two
the software will build on the benefits
of phase one and focus on technology
enhancements um
enhanced field mobility and real-time uh
data uh availability you know so in
essence
um
i'll go down to a brief description of
the project it really provides uh mobile
devices in connectivity across the
departments 100 plus permanent field
locations to enable easy and efficient
access to the system
they also provide additional resources
to insist
assist with the implementation system
and enhance the integration with
real-time data
so with that
i will pause
are there any questions from members of
the committee
on what was included
in the governor's proposal and that we
just went over for highway funding
i
yes thank you mr chairman i just
wondered with this work order
um
system
uh we've been asked to consider um
uh
with the emergency system and efficient
game
um it has there been any coordination
with this i mean in terms of
i guess
telecommunication i guess what i'm
so representative um this system is a
work order system
um so that we can
uh track both planned work as well as
accomplishments associated with
maintaining our assets and so this is
more about tracking people
um equipment material usage as well as
estimating and developing work plans for
each of our different asset types
whether that's
routine
preventative maintenance
or
assigning
tasks associated with advancing larger
scale projects
while we may use this to track you know
the status and assign um
work associated with communications
making sure that we're timely in
addressing um
maybe constituent issues that come in
this isn't really a communications type
project
when it comes to
our dispatch
solutions and our traffic management
systems we are actively engaged
across the state agencies and looking
for opportunities to have efficiency so
we work closely with department of
safety and homeland security
as well as fishing game and the others
that do
dispatch work and emergency response
work
representative evil
thank you mr chair and great to see
everyone from d.o.t and congratulations
to the commissioner our new president of
ashto
the question i had was just how are we
doing with the salt sheds i'm in my
fifth term i can't believe it on this
committee and it seems like we've been
replacing salt sheds for
quite a while are we making good
progress or
representative um i can answer that
question thank you for the question and
it's good to see you as well
in essence we try to replace about two
to three locations
you know per biennium um with the
funding that is allocated
and you know in some cases um and we'll
talk a little bit about
um you know a couple projects where we
need additional funds uh
costs have been increasing so we may get
down to you know instead of the two or
three that we planned we may only be
able to replace two
um but we where we have a lot of old
facilities that were you know
constructed not to any kind of modern
standard
um and
you know they're severely undersized
they worked in their day and age and and
now um
we need to i i can't say how many um we
you know the list i think that we had
probably list about eight of them
that um have been prioritized
you know so we keep on trying to whittle
just quick follow-up mr chair
um
are there other any opportunities for
consolidating the sheds or they really
need to be where they are
the sheds are in strategic locations to
save on travel you know particularly
um when you have a plow truck and
it does it's it's does its plowing route
um if the shed if they have to travel
you know
too far then it's way in addition to
wasted time it is really um you know
added cost on
fuel and all that so
they're really strategically you know
placed
and if i may it's really about public
safety um you know when we have
large-scale snow events
um
that's one thing we have one strategy
but if we have you know icing calls and
situations where we've unexpected
weather making sure that
trucks can get loaded and out on their
beats as quickly as possible that's
factoring into where we site and locate
these sheds as well
just quick i'd just be curious how many
we have if you at some point if it's
convenient if you could uh share that
so representative i do want to
acknowledge that dave rodrigue our
director of operations just joined us um
dave perhaps you could answer that
question
yes good morning representative and
members of the committee for the record
my name's david rodriguez i'm the
director of operations we do have about
a hundred salt sheds
across the state
so this is a capital budget item i
expect you to see for years and years to
come
if if we
replace two salt sheds per biennium
that assumes a life of a salt shed of a
hundred years um our salt sheds will not
last uh a hundred years
which is why we try to get three per
biennium when you think of the state of
new hampshire there's over 200 towns in
the state of new hampshire
when we think of consolidating winter
maintenance right now with the number of
facilities we have
each facility
covers the state roads within two towns
if we consolidate that too much as the
commissioner said we delay our response
and we come very inefficient because we
have many trucks doing what we call
dead heading driving over the same roads
without providing service so
we feel that um winter maintenance is
really a logistics effort
our current system was designed by
military officials after world war ii
they really set us up the way we're set
up now and we feel that that we have set
representative faulkner
yes thank you mr chairman
um my question i guess is
related somewhat to the fuel management
uh project but i was curious as to where
we are in terms of
alternative fuel vehicles for the state
fleet and whether that might change how
we
how we deal with the fueling
so dave as our director of operations
has been representing the department on
the electric charging commission um so
we've been engaged in conversations
about supporting the statewide effort to
build out
electric charging infrastructure but
then internally we've had conversations
about the greening of our own fleet
so dave do you want to touch on
where those conversations have led up
until now we've been focused on
purchasing more fuel-efficient vehicles
but not necessarily exploring
alternative fuel vehicles
would like to address that thank you
commissioner and thank you for the
question representative
faulkner we do we have historically
and we continue to look at incorporating
alternative fuel vehicles
in our fleet
unfortunately today there are still
limitations
in our all electronic vehicles or all
electric vehicles um with how far they
can travel
in the need to stop and charge that
vehicle during the day
when it comes to what we call a white
fleet or our light vehicles we continue
to watch the improvements in battery
technology
in ranges of vehicles and when the time
is right and we can do it most cost
effectively
we will move forward transitioning our
white fleet to to electric vehicles when
it comes to the heavy fleet i want you
to think of a large plow truck pushing a
very heavy load of snow
with a very heavy salt spreader in the
back that also takes power to control
with levers for plows that go up and
down
windshield wipers on heaters on radios
on lights on the technology simply is
not there today
to power that size of vehicle
um and frankly may not be for
for some time um so we continue to watch
the technology we're very interested in
it but it has to be at a time that makes
both economic and efficiency sense for
any other questions on this portion of
the presentation
seeing the commissioner
i
did hear a reduction of one from five
to
uh four million for the fuel management
system
and if i heard that correctly i believe
that leads into your next slide
yes so as chris explained
as we've worked through the capital
budget process um with public works
there was a significant increase in the
cost of the londonderry project um that
was just presented um so the next couple
of slides uh deal with projects that
were approved in
prior
um capital budgets that had not yet
entered construction
and so
just as we've seen
costs increase in some of the work that
we have completed
we've been working with public works to
understand what the
[Music]
appropriate amount to budget is for some
of our
previously approved projects so i'm
going to turn it over to chris he's
going to touch on
three projects where
we are concerned because the amount that
was approved um
during previous biennium you know may
not be adequate going forward um so in
addition
so in addition to talking about lapse
extensions later in the week um at chris
shea's recommendation he wanted us to
touch very briefly on this today and
then we can have a more robust
conversation when we come back for the
last presentation if that's appropriate
well it will also play into our
executive sessions when we get to that
but i want to be sure that you are very
confident that that reduction from 5 to
4 million
for that fuel management system
will stand the test of this biennium and
that when it goes to the senate you will
not have revised figures that say no it
has to be
4.5 or 5 million and so thank you for
that question mr chairman and we are
very confident so our strategy has been
as we prepare for capital budgets we
if we have a piece of software we want
to replace we do a rfi process and just
to see what different solutions are on
the market and that's how we came up
with the five million dollar amount that
we
included in our agency request
since then we have
been working on the procurement of that
new software so at the point that we're
at in the procurement process
we're very confident that we could
deliver that particular project for the
adjusted a budget amount of 4 million
thank you
so we've worked hard to time our
procurements to make sure that we have
the best possible information to inform
okay thank you mr chairman so these are
three uh capital
budget items that were previously
approved in past bienniums
since since the original appropriation
they've been progressed either
in an initial design or all the way up
to advertisement and and bids received
and the result has been that the costs
are uh dramatically higher so for
example the first one is the manchester
patrol shed um in this location in this
situation here um i knew and we had um
the existing patrol shed
was going to be renovated and
additions
included
and
design
moved forth
and then
because of because and the project was
advertised actually in in the spring of
2020 prior to covid and then it had to
be put on hold
um when covert hit because of
the impact on revenue and uncertainty
uh the bids at that time um that were
received exceeded the budget in public
works has also since indicated that the
current costs are even anticipated to be
about 10 to 20 percent higher than
um the bids received last spring
so therefore we are requesting an
additional uh one million dollars
um for this item the initial
appropriation was 2.1 million
and we believe the cost will now
be in the order of 3.1 million so
there's an additional million dollars
that the department's requesting for for
this item
the second item is in addition to the
lancaster district office
again design um
and construction work was recently
approved to advance but was delayed to
uh due to covid
this project does include an addition of
1500 square foot of office space i think
it renovates
the existing roughly 2 800 square foot
facility
this project will address state fire
marshal
office comments and will advertise for
construction once that design is
complete which we anticipate to be
shortly
uh design estimates from public works
prior to covet exceeded the budget and
now public works has also indicated that
the common costs are anticipated to be
even
higher than that by 10 to 20 percent so
therefore we are requesting an increase
of 450 000
for this item the initial appropriation
was 760 000
so we are requesting this to be amended
to 1.21 million
and lastly the third one was the
district patrol shed
um
the initial appropriation for this item
was 1.4 million
it was for design and construction of a
new patrol shed up in dixville
on property that was acquired by the
department from the balsams
this project actually has been bid twice
and put on hold
uh most recently mo after after the
latest bit due to covert um
uh
in essence and also since that time the
design will need to be revised to meet
all the regulatory items and address
state fire marshal office comments uh
bids where we were much higher
than budget and
public works has indicated the current
costs are anticipated to be even 10 to
20 higher
so therefore we're requesting seven
hundred thousand dollars to properly
fund this item
um so we're requesting this be amended
to 2.1 million so in total uh this would
these three editions
total 2.15 million
and if we re we reduce um the
fuel management system by a million
it's a net change of
1.15 million
that is needed
and with that i'll be happy to answer
any questions
representative jack
thank you mr chairman this being highway
funded makes it easier to do
but
it does it would impact the hospital one
operating highway fund
can um marie mullen tell us what the
debt service impact on the actual
highway fund cash flow would be if we
were to do this
uh yes representative jack thank you for
the question
um
in in reviewing uh for this change um
i have had conversations with the
department uh the state treasury and in
december they went out for a refunding
on several
bonds that were previously issued
a portion of those bonds were related to
the highway fund into
dot projects
and we have identified savings related
to those refunding so we have
approximately
740 000 over the next 10 years of
savings related to those that could
offset this
and
with the savings
in fy 22 and 23
we believe we have sufficient funds in
the operating budget to cover this
any other questions
so if we were to ex
yes
thank you
i'm going to apologize ahead of time
because this might be a real stupid
question for the experts but are all of
these patrol sheds do they all have to
be designed and constructed for the
particular site they're on or is there
any
capability for
one or two or four designs specific that
would fit into new hampshire so they
could be almost
constructed off-site like a modular home
and delivered to a um
the first two projects representative um
are both additions or renovations of
existing spaces um so unfortunately that
occurred it wouldn't work
um
the we've looked at this with public
works in the past if there's sort of a
standard design but you know each of our
sites is so different
the facilities
that we are
replacing um
serve different purposes
um
dave touched on it earlier but our crew
size from shed to shed is quite
different um some sheds we have a small
number of state employees but we have a
large number of contractors there in the
winter
other sheds we have a much larger
workforce year-round um
and their state positions that are
responsible for maintaining the roadway
so
um no two sheds are the same
unfortunately
i don't know if perhaps dave um all
thank you mr chair um this is just in
anticipation of getting some other kind
of questions regarding this i i
personally don't have any problem with
these figures however i want to be able
to answer the question should it come up
how your uh original let's just and i
noticed this common for all three of
these projects
your original all three of them say that
you're anticipating 10 to 20 percent
higher costs
and let's just go with that 20
figure let's say they're all going to be
20 higher costs and yet you're asking
for all three of them
over 50
of the original budget
so how do we reconcile that
should the question come up
because we went up 20 you're asking for
50 over the original budget on all three
of them
so representative thank you for the
question and and that's a good
observation um the 20 percent
the 10 to 20 percent higher is is
based on
um higher than the bids we received last
spring summer when covet hit
so
when when those bids came in they were
higher than the the the budget and now
since that time uh costs have even
increased by 10 20 we've actually used
the roughly 15 figure to come up with
the uh the additional amount requested
but
um in the case of manchester and
dixville
the bids that were received uh came in
considerably higher than the the budget
thank you that's that's
exactly what i wanted to hear
you're welcome
representative evil
thank you um
i i'm just curious it seems like there's
a lot of pent-up demand for construction
in the state and i wondered what you
thought your how your schedule would be
and
if you get your projects done there'll
be fewer cost overruns in the future so
i just wondered if you had any thoughts
on that
yeah so we rely heavily on the bureau of
public works for these estimates frankly
um
they they hire the architect and the
consultant and come up with with
the cost estimates for work that is you
know way more on the
highways and bridges um and they're more
experts in the building area but um with
all that said
um we do
you know so
we we will need approval of this item so
we cannot
we cannot award the contract until
after june so we're targeting probably a
july time frame uh to be able to award a
contract and we've kind of backed things
in so if we get a positive response from
from this committee
we may put these bids out in
maybe the may time frame um
you know certainly
we can't put them out as of yet too soon
without knowing that we have approval
for this additional increase
but
we are hopeful that
it's going to be a competitive process
and the estimates that public works has
provided us um are going to be
you know in line with what um what the
bidding environment will be you know
that time frame but i agree with you
representative it seems like there's a
lot of pent up demand
see no other questions i do have one on
this
um
by you like if we were to accept this by
using that one million that you say you
can save
from the
what is in house bill 25 currently we
still have to come up with a million in
change
to fund this
which means that anything additionally
you ask for
is on top of that
1.15 million
am i correct
chris
yes that is correct representative
now i'm mr shay
thank you represent graham i just wanted
to jump in for a moment
um
just to make if the committee is is um
thinking this is something they might
like to do
that one approach to to taking care of
this instead of going back to the three
projects that are identified
individually and
um amending the appropriations back in
those house bill 25s you could just put
a new section in this house bill 25
for the appropriation of 2.15 million
dollars
um you could leave it as a as a block
amount so that would give a little
flexibility to the department in case
it's 20 in one instance but only a 10
increase in another instance so they
could move some money between those
three projects
i mean we could have it tied again to
those three projects if it was a new
appropriation in this budget otherwise
if you go back to those
existing projects
you're going to see a lot of language in
house bill 25
striking
amounts and putting new amounts in and
um it becomes
more confusing to look at and to try to
explain so it's just a suggestion unless
the department has um a strong desire to
go back and amend the previous capital
budget or do not want to group
the dollars into a single appropriation
for the three projects
uh thank you mr shea i just made a note
of that but when we get into our actual
work sessions and exec sessions
if i forget if somebody on the committee
or from lba would remind me so that we
can at least discuss this uh this
mr chairman if i may the department
very much supports what
it probably would work easier assuming
that we
any other questions on this
section and proposal on these three
prior appropriations
if not
unfunded med um
desires
before we go to that uh mr chairman i'm
sorry i think perhaps representative
thompson has a question i don't think he
raised his hand electronically but i've
seen him motion a couple of times on my
screen
well with with screen sharing i don't
see much um representative thompson
um thank you mr chairman and
commissioner
um
with respect to the dicksville project
which is in my district
um
this has kind of been a
topic of discussion in the north country
for a number of years now
since the balsams project seemed to come
alive
and has since basically died
um the original figure that we heard for
relocating the shed
that's up there currently was a half a
million dollars
and now we're up to 1.4 million dollars
um
and i think probably um
chris's assumption that the costs are
going to be 50 percent higher or this
there is virtually no work in the north
carolina i've owned a construction
company for 45 years
so i can tell you that that's true i
would think that this could be done much
cheaper than this
and i still question the need for it um
maybe you can explain to me
why we need this
i guess it's my basic question
so representative thompson thank you for
the question i'll let dave rodrigue
address the history of this particular
project and on the cost estimates
and explain from an operations
perspective why we really
so thank you very much for for the
question and it gives me an opportunity
to address a couple of things
the first thing is please be assured
that the department of transportation
is as disappointed as everybody
with the increase in cost for these
projects that that we
we see um
i get sticker shock every time i i see
an estimate however
every building we construct needs to
follow every
building code every state fire marshall
requirement every requirement that the
legislature puts on buildings for energy
efficiency and everything else which we
support they're they're good in the long
run
however
they do drive up the cost of
construction
with respect to lancaster and dixville
um those estimates are higher because
those projects are in the north country
these these the contractors for these
projects will be determined by low bid
so anybody is welcome to bid on them and
we strongly um would like some some
lower bids and some lower costs to
construct these and hopefully we will
see that
um but we have not seen that recently
certainly in the new shed in lisbon we
did not see that we we saw increases
um we did look as as others have
suggested this morning at consolidation
the dixville
patrol shed has nothing to do with the
balsams and the balsams resort it has
everything to do with dicksville notch
in route 26 in the micro climate that
exists there in the trucks that start
driving through there at three in the
morning trying to get up through the
notch
and we need this local shed that is not
staffed 24 7
365 days a year
it is staffed during the winter time
to have people there available to
continuously keep that notch open so
that commerce can move through the north
country if there was a way to
consolidate this we we would do that but
we would not be able to keep route 26
open the way it has been
um
let's see no other questions
and i would reiterate what i've said
before about if you want to ask a
question please raise your electronic
hand right now
i can only see
a small fraction of those who are on the
zoom
so plea please do that commissioner that
your unfunded
needs
which are going to be a harder sell even
so we wanted to
very quickly just walk you through some
of these projects to give you a sense of
the work that
was not unfortunately supported in the
governor's phase
primarily because we saw that
significant cost increase in the
londonderry project
we talked earlier about our strategy
when it comes to
estimating the capital budget needs for
software projects you know we've been
trying to time our procurements to have
good information and solid uh cost data
to inform the process
likewise we've been trying to advocate
um
for the design funds for our
uh
capital
vertical construction projects um in one
biennium so that we can advance the
design adequately to then have real
numbers when we're talking about what
the cost of construction is going to be
um and trying to secure those dollars um
so the remaining projects that chris is
going to go through very quickly um
this week these were requests for design
funds only to be able to advance some
projects and then have good numbers as
we go into the next capital budget
and are advocating for dollars for
construction and so these are all
different building projects
um
and these estimates are designed only
chris
yes so thank you commissioner um so
actually this first one was not just for
design this was for a roof replacement
um this was our sixth priority um in
total the the the five prior the five
items that were not funded by the
governor i think total roughly 2.2 2.3
million this one here was a little under
300 000 it was to replace an existing
roof uh that was constructed in 16 1969
um it's an aluminum roof that was
designed with only two inches of
insulation which has caused some issues
with um with snow and ice melt um and
frankly it has caused some damage to the
building and certainly a serious issue
when large sheets of snow and ice uh
slide off the building um you know
certainly we would also uh by by
completing this um this roof replacement
we would also see some energy
efficiencies
um but um
you know we realize we need to
prioritize uh items so this uh this um
just to make the cut um
and i think next slide will show a
picture of the facility um
and you know certainly i think this is
an item that that can wait until the
next biennium
next next slide
uh this was actually for um it was 200
thousand dollars for the design of this
patrol shed facility as the commissioner
noted we'd like to get the design
started so we can get a better idea of
what the construction um cost would be
uh so we can put that forth um at the
you know in the next biennium this
facility is um over 90 years old um it
is undersized um it does not meet modern
uh building codes uh electric codes and
mechanical codes you know so certainly
this facility is
um
a facility that will need to be
addressed in the near future
and the next slide kind of shows
a picture of of the facility um
and then you know
kind of shows how cramped the facility
is when you put a plow truck inside
um this is
the milford patrol shed again
replacement design i believe this was
roughly three hundred thousand um
dollars excuse me three hundred fifty
thousand dollars for this design uh this
facility was built in 1939 so
um
over 80 years old
it is also undersized does not meet um
not capable of storing all the uh all
the maintenance vehicles
does not meet modern building codes uh
is obsolete and
um you know really what we're reviewing
here is to site um
a new facility on the existing property
uh again this was just for the design to
better understand what the construction
funding needs are and that would be uh
asked to be appropriated uh at in the
future um biennium
uh and next slide kind of shows a
picture of the facility um if you go on
the next slide
um kind of again cramped quarters when
you when you start to insert um the plow
trucks inside the facility i believe
this facility can't even
house
a plow truck with all the equipment
which is certainly problematic because
we mount the equipment at the start of
the winter and do not take the equipment
off until after the winter is completed
next slide
this is um again a request for five
hundred thousand dollars to start the
design for
a new satellite garage
for the lancaster mechanical services
mechanical
services
bureau you know the existing structure
was constructed in 1981
so certainly not as old as the other
facilities but this layout of this
building is obsolete and really unsafe
it lacks the ability to lift fleet
vehicles in the air
um
you know right now vehicles need to
slide under
excuse me employees need to slide under
underneath um heavy fleet units so it is
problematic in that regard not very
efficient um
and also not uh not
ergonomic um
several pictures are shown
on the next page of this facility again
this is not a typical mechanical
services
garage that you would you would see
and lastly um the last item
um there was you know unfunded list was
500 000 and this is actually not a
design this is for the continued
replacements of our under underground
fuel tank
replacement program um as you know the
department currently has roughly 40 fuel
sites that have underground storage
tanks
and apprentices that are 25 years older
each biennium we try to
allocate one to two million dollars
for this program to replace the most
the most efficient or oldest
underground storage tanks to prevent any
environmental issues
from from
resulting
um you know and at the bottom of the
page there under uh item three it just
shows um several several locations where
we have tanks that are that are over 30
years old
and you know potentially problematic
from from an environmental standpoint so
um
this is an area that we we have we try
to replace
um one to two to three tanks um a year
um and um you know certainly this is an
area that um
we we uh we
try to advocate for in each biennium
so those were the five items you know
certainly we understand
the um precarious nature of
the highway fund and
the situation
um but we want to present these items to
the committee to give the committee an
understanding of
which five items we we saw as a priority
but due to
primarily the increased cost for the
londonderry location
we're not able to move forward with
thank you any questions from members of
the committee
on this
representative newman uh representative
newman yes
thank you
um could i just ask is there a
an alarm system or something set up in
case any of the underground
tanks get compromised or how do you
determine if there's been a compromise
and they're leaking
dave can you answer that please
yes so so the modern tank design has two
two tanks it's essentially a tank in a
tank
and there is what we call an
interstitial alarm that will go off and
let us know if a tank has been ruptured
in fact one of our tanks in in lancaster
several years ago
um we did have a rupture in the interior
tank the alarm um worked properly
our fix was to to pump that tank and
send professionals in not d.o.t folks
put professional tank repair folks in to
fix that tank and that tank is still in
service part of the crux
behind this replacement um is to make
sure we do not get to that point where
we have leakages because of course um
any any fuel leakages are environmental
concerns and one of the the dot's
principles is to be sure that we are
representative ebal
thank you mr chair uh my question has to
do with the underground tanks as well um
you said you're it's sort of like the
salt shed things you're you're always
advocating to keep up to date on these
tanks
um
how are we doing with that i don't know
if we we
funded any replacements in the last
biennium i see the chair nodding
um
i just was curious how we're doing i see
it's your last priority but it's an
so representative i believe last year we
uh funded it at the million-dollar level
i think in years past it's been funded
at a two million dollar level
i will say dave rodriguez can um
can
jump in but i will say we've been we've
addressed the most serious locations
um however
whenever a location gets to be better
than 30 years old we start having
concerns
um because
we're you know
we don't want to get into a situation
where we're reactive and have
environmental issues we've got to be
proactive and replace these
um
sooner rather than later and we do have
i think there's eight or nine sites
listed there they're better than 30
years old so uh this is um
this is a looming liability
you know and you know certainly
we'll be coming back at the next
biennium
with the request
okay follow up mr chair follow-up so
if i understood what just as we're going
forward into work sessions and whatever
if i understand your request the 240 is
for two or three of them i mean would a
lesser amount that you could pay for one
be helpful or is there some way to split
that up a little bit if we just wanted
so representative i believe this request
was for 500 000 and i believe that
allows us
i'm sorry
can you hear me okay yeah yeah i've
misread the thing yeah so it's for 500
000 i believe it allows us to address
one to two locations um
if if that and dave can you know maybe
you can
um
yes if if if i may the the 500 000 would
would be something would be something to
allow us to do some some work it may
allow us to replace a a smaller site
um or it may allow us to do some of the
tank top upgrades if we go back to the
pictures
um one of the things that a modern
installation
is required to have
is a full concrete pad with no cracks in
it and be able to
um catch any potential fuel that has
been leaking so if you see the picture
in my well if if fuel leaks it's going
to run off from that concrete pad and go
through the cracks in the in the
concrete and into the the ground
um
that's not an environmentally compliant
site we need a full concrete pad there
with the the grooves in it to catch any
fuel that leaks and when we do that we
also need to replace the piping and
other things underneath
if there is not a modern tank underneath
it doesn't make sense to do that full
improvement and then to dig it up in
four or five years when we do get the
capital funds to replace the tank which
is why we typically request the amount
of two million per biennium to allow us
to do
two to four of these sites per year to
to keep up with them
but the 500 000 would allow us to
address some of these and if we couldn't
get the 500 and got 250 that's certainly
that was kind of my question thank you
um thank you and i was going to ask a
lot of those same questions because i
know for several by india
we have been doing these replacements
and it would be
unfortunate if we had to stop so the
question would be in my mind not having
looked
is there
any
money for this that you're extending in
in lapse extensions so that work can
representative if i may um
so last the last biennium i was mistaken
we received
um two million dollars for for these
upgrades and you know certainly um we
are continuing to work on sites we
actually have a couple sites that we're
going to be putting out to bid
soon to to address two locations and i
believe we're looking at
two other locations that
we may need additional money to
be able to progress all all four however
um you know we were gonna
we would we're
proceeding with putting two out to bid
to see what the bids were
and then assessing whether um the other
two could go or whether we needed to uh
we needed additional money so
um you know certainly
any additional funds uh for this effort
would be appreciated um
[Applause]
i hope that
it does thank you
any other questions of the department on
what they have presented today
representative mcconkey
thank you mr chairman um
gentlemen can you remind me why um why
the state is not able to use odd funds
to
make these uh
replacements
i will turn that question over to
i i will take uh uh
my understanding is odd fund is for
leaking to address the leaking locations
uh these are not leaking as of yet and
we certainly do not want them to leak
um so
um i i believe
that is why and maybe dave um
understands it uh better or differently
you you explained it correctly
when we have leaky tanks that create
contamination
we are able to use odd funds and we have
used odd funds to help clean up the
contaminated soil
um unfortunately odd funds uh are used
not as a proactive measure but as a
measure to come in after and clean up
the mess um not to help us keep modern
equipment to avoid a mess in the in the
first place
mr chairman if i could follow up
go ahead
thank you
um
so
[Music]
people that dispense gasoline not the
state
were mandated to replace all their tanks
a number of years ago
and so how were we able to avoid that
as the state
we met all the state requirements and um
when the requirements for double line
tanks came into two place
we were in compliance with with that
that requirement there was also a
derefds requirement after the the double
line tanks to have double lined piping
to the the pumps um that was an issue
that we we did an in-house project
largely to come into
compliance with those des requirements
as well so we are required to meet every
regulation that the private industry is
required to meet
and then the the other important aspect
of our fuel distribution system
is it meets the needs not not only of
the dot
although we have the big use
for diesel um it means meets the needs
of other state agencies local
municipalities
and
some non-profit organizations as well
and serves as the state strategic
reserve should a
national event occur there'd be a fuel
shortage we have a the state of new
hampshire has a supply of fuel that can
be rationed and used to respond to
thank you
see no
more one more thing mr chairman
go ahead
thank you um hate to get in the way of
lunch here
so we have another presentation
thank you our our tanks are uh compliant
they're not leaking so we can't use odd
fund
as i believe uh
chairman campbell had investigated that
at length a number of years ago
but it's clear it's clear that your
your surface doesn't even come close to
or your earlier conversation when you're
talking about driving in and any waste
fuel is collected in the
concrete apron and held by grooves
so i'm somewhat confused i guess we can
commissioner i wish to thank you and all
of your staff for coming in
and trying to answer our questions and
doing your presentation and i do
appreciate the fact that you
did shorten your presentation somewhat
from your original
uh booklet that you sent out to all of
us so that we could get through this
and i am sure that if we have additional
questions about any of this
that
you and your staff will be able to
answer them for us as we go forward
don't hesitate to reach out we're ready
um to respond i know you're on a tight
deadline in terms of approving
hb 25.
and i thank you
now as i said at the start of this
morning we do have one additional agency
that has requested to make a
presentation today
something has come up at ports and
harbors and
gino marconi is online
and ready to
do his presentation now
um it is important that we hear this
and because we will need to discuss it
thank you thank you mr chairman members
of the committee uh for the record
genome icony the director of the
division of ports and harbors
uh and with me today is paul breen he's
the executive director of the pease
development authority
and and i welcome the opportunity to to
talk about this the discussion is the
uppermost turning basin in this in the
deep watership channel here in piscata
this this project was first identified
in a navigation safety improvement study
that was published by the army corps of
engineers back in
1987.
uh
the deep water channel is a federal
navigation channel and it's designed and
maintained by the corps of engineers
and in that study there were five
projects office navigation safety that
were identified
this is the last one of those
of those projects
and i will tell you that
there's been 20 years of my time trying
to move this forward
so what happened was
uh the court came to us back in around
2015 said oh yeah we're going to get
ready to do this
and uh they estimated the
local sponsor being the state of new
hampshire the cost share
and we submitted a capital request to
that
and then at the same time we we
submitted a capital request for the post
construction
contribution to operations and
maintenance
um
obviously the corps of engineers did not
get the funding
but this last session of congress
uh through um um a lot of push by our
senate delegation
uh the uppermost turning basin project
was included in the water resource
development act
uh it was a very specific saying that
the corps of engineers shall
do this project
so back in the end of december we got
notified by
the district
down in
massachusetts that
the project was put on the 2021 work
schedule
so
they they told me that they were going
to go back and they were going to
re-estimate the project
and
no surprise
on the car the cost of the project uh
went up
uh so
[Music]
our estimates
according to what they provided us
is that
we're about a million five hundred
thousand dollars short on this project
um we have
um
we have seven million two hundred and
forty one thousand five hundred and
fifty dollars uh in that
those original appropriations
and uh
they're telling us that uh
it's uh it's an additional
the cost share is gonna be over over
eight million dollars and so we're a
million five short
um
this is this is a one-time thing with
the corps of engineers
if we don't do this project now they're
gonna divert that
this uh the total project cost is 24
million dollars so uh
that this is the state's cost share in
this if the if this project doesn't get
done they're going to divert those funds
to another harbor and and who knows who
knows when this opportunity is going to
come up again
the the importance of this project um
when that
the uppermost turning basin is
800 feet wide
our state pilots are turning 764-foot
ships around in that in that turning
basin
and uh it's uh
the safety factor is greatly reduced
um
the project calls for expanding the
turning basin to 1200 feet
so that would give us a safety factor so
[Music]
what they what they're moving up there
is uh
petroleum products lpg uh bulk carriers
carrying road salt and uh
and uh gypsum rock
um
so it's it's an important
important
part of marine transportation here
i can just give you an example
of how this affects the whole state
um
first off
a few years ago we
russ cadell was at the university of new
hampshire that at the time it was one of
his phd students matt magnuson and then
professor colson from the university of
maine participated in this
this is not including what goes on of
course with naval shipyard
but in the local economy at that time
there were
987 direct jobs
from the
16 businesses utilizing the terminals
here at the at the
in the harbor
and it was over 90 million dollars of
direct wages and benefits paid to those
those people that work there
and
but the total regional impacts they
estimated
included 2300 jobs
and over two thousand or just over two
thousand were in new hampshire
and uh
there was a 156 million dollars in wages
and benefits are generated there
what was in what was interesting was uh
90 percent of the economic impacts from
the terminals
in the piscataqua river is in new
hampshire only 10 percent of it is in
the state of maine so
that's a brief overview of the economics
of it
getting down into the nuts and bolts of
it a little bit mr chairman um
the effect on the state
and
i looked at this a couple of years ago
when we were working with the state
freight transportation study committee
and
so
back in 2016
which is the information that i tried to
pull together
the census identified that there were
over 520 000 households in the state of
new hampshire
and 60 of those households heat with
home heating oil
and the scatter core river terminals up
there where the turning basin is
provides 85 of that home heating oil to
those houses
and so
what we looked at
well how do we how do we get that home
heating oil to those homes from those
households
so we looked at
the amount of liquid asphalt that comes
into the terminals up there where the
turning basin is
and
i'll boil it down that in
2017 there was enough liquid asphalt to
pave uh
3 500 road lane miles highway
and then
you look at it and you say well okay
we're going to bring this home heating
oil over these roads that have been
paved
but how do we keep them open
and
we keep them open and they only they're
only delivering this oil mostly in the
wintertime so we looked at the road song
and we came up with some numbers that
uh you know there was over a half a
million tons of road salt just
discharged in the in the terminals along
the river
and uh
and back in 2017
new hampshire d.o.t
used
225 000 tons of that road salt
and 85 percent of that came from the
terminals here in the river
though those numbers have gone up since
then because uh
there are two
two of the road salt companies that are
operating in the harbor here
uh
got the majority of the
districts for d.o.t so
that's an example of the importance of
traffic here
but
going back to the turning basin when it
was originally constructed the largest
ship that was coming into the harbor was
a jumbo wise t2 tanker which is about
524 feet long
today we have tugging badge units
delivering home heating oil and kerosene
up the river
there that are bigger than that and then
we have the lpg tankers uh bringing
propane to the terminal up there that
are 700 plus feet long so the importance
of expanding
this turning basin from
800 feet to 1200 feet
from a navigation safety standpoint
i think it's rather obvious that
we
the radius of the turning basin
needs to be
improved
to protect the environment
to protect the people that live along
the river
to allow more efficient uh uh
transportation of these products that
the citizens of new hampshire need
the transit restrictions that have been
placed on the ships coming in here on
daylight only
uh if they're carrying a certain amount
of product they only allow them to come
in on high tide
uh if there are if there's reduced
visibility or a certain amount of wind
factor
it causes delays and the ships are
coming and going
and a ship that may be stuck at the
terminal up the river because they can't
leave because of the restrictions of the
turning basin
uh the demerged fees on a ship that's
delayed
can be upwards of 80 or 85 000 a day and
those extra costs go back to the
consumer
um
that's the that's the cliff notes
version mr chairman and i
i apologize
i i know i was allowed to come in here
at the last minute so i don't have
there are a lot of familiar faces on
this committee that i've
talked to this about before
thank you miss marconi and i would point
out that
this morning while we've been in
committee there was a
presentation that that miss marconi had
put together about the basin
powerpoint presentation was emailed to
everybody i would ask that the committee
look at that not now but at some point
and we'll take a couple of questions
representative jack
thank you mr chairman thank you director
it's always a pleasure to see you
can you tell us what the source of funds
for this is i think in some previous
projects you've had your own source of
funds rather than general funds
uh
thank you for that uh in the in the
appropriation from 2015
which uh was 500 5 million and 355
500 dollars
of that 285
550.
uh
we're going to be responsible for paying
those bonds back to the general fund
other other than that is
this money is just the state of capital
appropriation
thank you mr chairman
uh my question is
um
and i recall um
voting on this prior
but
um is the state of maine going to
contribute anything to this uh
project
no no they are not served and uh
part of that
part of that is that um
90 percent of the economic benefit is in
representative thompson
thank you mr uh chairman and mr director
is
i don't know a lot about the river but i
know a little bit about it is this
turning area up by the propane terminal
yes sir it's it's just up above the
propane terminal uh propane terminal is
on avery lane
and then the next
the last terminal up is on river road
just just before you make the turn in
the river to go under
the two bridges connecting newington and
if this is done by the uh core
uh what's gonna happen to the waste
over three quarters of a million dollars
in into
the planning of this project
uh and those funds the majority of those
funds did come from
um the division here ourselves from our
one of our restricted funds part of the
design
uh and permitting for this was
identification of an offshore
uh disposal site
uh just out up east of the isles of
shoals uh there was a considerable
amount of expense that went in there
because that was required in the base
plan
here's the interesting part of what
happened during the delay of this
project was
it's been determined that there's a
beneficial use of this
material because uh ninety percent of it
is high packed glacial sand there's very
very little ledge or rock involved in
this
and so the corps of engineers
made it available to other communities
along the seacoast for beach nourishment
and there's a there's a tremendous
amount of
interest in it down in the salisbury
beach we've all read in the newspapers
about how
uh plum island and newbury massachusetts
and even his fire are down the scituate
mass
are
all interested in the sand
uh and then the corps did come up with a
grant program to assist these
communities to pay the difference in the
transportation costs so if the cost of
taking the material
to the base disposal site
is going to go to newbury massachusetts
and transportation costs
are more than what the base plan called
for the municipality was going to be
responsible for making those costs
and then sold the state of massachusetts
and
the municipalities working with the
corps
have made that sand available so
considerable amount of that
sand is going to go down for beach
nourishment sir
follow up mr chairman
go ahead
um
is this going this material going to be
put ashore and de-watered and trucked
down or is it going to go by barge
it goes by badge sir okay
all right thank you very much i
appreciate it yes sir
thank you mr chair thank you mr marconi
so if you're increasing a turning radius
i mean as i envision it you're
increasing the circumference of the area
where things can turn i mean who own do
you have like right away to the
adjoining land or
because you're expanding that opening i
and maybe i just don't understand well
it's it's i'm trying to i'm trying to
think of how to put it the army corps of
engineers um
takes takes ownership of the waterways
all the way to the high watermark
um
legal issue
that you know the state of new hampshire
controls the submerged lands under that
water that's
under the jurisdiction of the army corps
of engineers
98 of this project is over on the main
side of the river
so there are there are some permits that
the corps of engineers had to secure
from the state of maine but
it's basically
state and federally jointly owned
property i guess it's i'm not the legal
eagle on this one
okay thank you
robert edgar
uh thank you mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question captain marconi
um this project by increasing the uh the
length of the of the uh of the ships
but also combined with the fact that we
can get bigger bigger ships up
underneath or through the sarah long
bridge now
seemed like it would be quite a benefit
for the uh for the economy
here and it was really good to see uh
see this this money being
recently released you know by the
federal government so could you maybe
expand upon expand a little bit on the
uh
the effect on the economy of
having this project complete
sure um
this has been going on now for
the past number of years and and
the real the real push behind it was the
expansion of the uh
panama canal
uh there was a whole new set of locks
built uh next to the existing panama
canal that would handle larger ships
uh for example container ships that you
know traditionally carried
uh five or six thousand teus now they've
got ships that are carrying 19 000 teus
and these larger ships on the scale of
economy and efficiency
uh you're putting more cargo on a larger
ship reducing the transportation costs
so these larger ships are displacing
ships that had traditionally been on
uh on
these routes and those ships are
displacing the smaller ships that we had
historically seen come in here
so
um as those smaller ships are retiring
we're seeing larger ships
um
in the in the northeast sector are
handling cargo um another factor that
was taken into consideration here is
that
um so so that that kind of deals with
the length of the ship but also
um ships are getting wider which goes to
representative
edgar's comment about the sarah long
bridge
the naval architects have
determined that
they can put a percentage more cargo on
a ship
by making it a wider instead of longer
and not and not re and not require more
draft
so
we're seeing we're seeing these older
ships that historically came in here
being retired
which is why we're seeing now these 765
foot ships uh coming into the harbor and
they're being displayed and the older
ships are being displaced by
a larger more efficient ship
i hope that answers your question
oh yes thank you very much captain
thank you chairman
you're welcome
uh captain marconi seeing no other
questions thank you
and i would
um
again mention that there is that
powerpoint presentation which shows
where the basin will be in relation to
the bridges and all the rest um which
will is helpful in visualizing what
we're talking about and this is
something that we will have to do
um
because i believe the way the language
is written
at the federal level if we do not
support this
then we do not get the work done
for the foreseeable future am i correct
in that you know
you're always correct mr chairman
most of the committee won't agree with
you but thank you
well i thank you for the opportunity to
uh to crash your party here and and say
what i had to say and
um
most of you have my phone number please
don't hesitate to call me and i'm sure
i'll be back up and and
you mentioned 1.5 if you could give us
some
if that's the number that's fine if you
have a more refined number it would be
helpful to provide to mr shea or to
myself
so that we can have that in our
discussions
yes so that that does have about a
hundred thousand dollar contingency
because the course still hasn't
fine-tuned
uh what the cost of the mitigation is
going to be the yield
thank you yes sir
all right see no other questions for the
pr on the presentations
um
the committee will stand in recess until
1 pm
where we will have a full committee work
session
on the presentations it is my intention
as i said earlier
to begin talking about the presentations
and see if we can't
reach agreement on
on several of them
so that when we meet again next week and
the week after
we are only talking about those that
may be increased or decreased as the
case may be
so with that the committee is in recess
until 1pm
if members could start taking their
i was listening to sb43
very interesting
mr chair lisa bunker
hi lisa
um just a quick note um i have to leave
the meeting at two we've got a bandwidth
conflict here at my house my my wife's
doing a presentation on live on live
zoom and if i'm on at the same time i
tend to crash those so i'll be out it
too
um
yep keeping the family happy is
important
we have like one more minute i do like
to
start on time
and it's fortunate that we are all at
home and can grab something to eat
having run over into the lunch hour
so in this committee room one side isn't
crushed into the wall and the other side
isn't
now that tended to change depending on
when they reset the room from doubles
and not
[Music]
okay i
would like to call the
this work session of public works and
highways
to order
um first just one announcement as i said
earlier
today
on the 16th
we will be holding
the public hearing on house bill 25
and then following that with a work
session
that will be a hybrid meeting um
the speaker is asked at public hearings
if at all possibly done in
in um in a hybrid fashion
so
um some of us will be in
the lob
the rest are encouraged to attend but
may
uh elect to do so virtually
um
now that we're back in session for this
work session
are there any questions that any members
have
from any of the agencies
that have presented
if you do if you could write them down
and send them to me and or mr shea
we will try to get an answer for you
none of them are on the call at the
moment i don't think
um but i do want to try to get
the um
questions that you may have answered
about particular products
projects not products projects
before
we go into
further work sessions representative
clutier
yeah just to to ask a follow-up when
will the public hearing be next tuesday
tuesday morning at 9 30. okay all right
thank you and there'll be a work session
to follow after that right that's
correct okay thank you anything that we
talk about or
or reach consensus on today as we're
going forward
can be changed as a result of hearing
from the public i don't want the public
to think that we are trying to get ahead
of them but we have limited amount of
time and a limited amount of
zoom licenses to go forward so we need
first up
what i want to do
is reach consensus as i said on some
um agencies requests
that have um
little or no changes or no changes
actually
and no controversy when we were asking
questions
but before we get to that
i just have
two items that we have to think about
um first up
is uh
house bill 595
which is the supreme court records
we're talking
money in this biennium money in the next
biennium to digitize the supreme court
is we retain that bill
to think about
um
as you remember there is a
absence of anybody wants to claim
responsibility to to take on the project
the archivist when i talk to
him
uh then talk uh email back and forth
um is interested in the idea but he
needs a lot more information
do
we want to
the only question i'm going to ask about
that today is do we want to discuss this
further in another work session yay or
nay any comments
we're talking
i forget the the exact dollar amount but
i would say yes mr chairman
um okay but remember we're playing zero
sum game in in lots of cases here
um
all right we will
bring that up again at a future work
session
the second one is house bill i think
it's 122 on freight rails
um do we want to
um
continue to to pursue any monies for
them
in this capital budget at a future work
session
yay or nay folks
uh
i i would say yes to that mr chair
okay representative mills representative
clutier
representative claudia
unmute yourself
thank you sorry about that mr chairman
uh
former representative campbell called me
said he didn't think he need as much
money as or you know for the railroad as
in the previous capital budget that was
my understanding
um he called me as well and and rather
than asking for what's in that bill he
was talking somewhere in the
neighborhood of 300 000 but we still
have the other rail that we would have
to discuss
and try to find room within the capital
budget
remembering that we're already over what
the treasurer
has recommended be the maximum mile
along with everybody else who has asked
so we will
representative evil
yeah just to refresh our recollection as
we start in this so
i think that the governor's budget was
what like
127 in general funds
and then was the treasurer in the
vicinity of 125 i just i'm trying to
remember the treasurer recommended 120.
uh
yes
your
shock is noted representative evil but
that was her recommendation
um she was going to try to be on today
but
there was a conflict with with other
um committees and
and her other business
i will try to get her on um at a future
work session to talk a little bit about
it
but um
the way 125 is structured
we are at 124 788.
um so right at the 125.
um the only thing that dropped out was
2.5 million dollars for the cte in
hudson so anything that we add goes
above
above that
unless we substitute projects for
representative jack ah thank you have we
had any uh last last biennium uh the
senate started out with we're going over
what the treasurer said have we had any
discussions this time with the senate
about what their plan is for that
uh no i have not
um
but i can before our next work session
i i'm not sure with the way they're
doing omnibus bills that they've even
thought about doing the either the
budget or the capital budget
mr shea i believe that's your hand
it is represented graham i was just
wondering if it would be helpful for me
to share the comparison report
so all members can see the same document
and then we can
people that would be helpful
well
i i did mail it to everybody but i i
don't i'm just asking if you don't want
raise your hand if you think it would be
useful to have it up
and i don't see a lot of hands
yes i i just with the railroad there
in my is my memory correct and uh thank
you mr chairman but is my memory
correctly saying this is the last
installment
on the railway deal
on
on one of them
the the lobbyists did say that if we
gave them the full 2 million that for
that one railroad that would complete it
but that's a two million dollar general
fund project that we would have to add
any money we give them would be matched
um
so i think that we need to postpone that
discussion
until we start dealing with all of the
requests from people like
um hhs corrections and others who have
asked for additional
general fund yeah thank you i i just got
that confused with the
capitol
what i would like to do
today is i said the ones i don't think
we're going to have a lot of problems
with i just wanted to see if we wanted
to to discuss those two things
further
if we could find the room for them but
we shall see
all right first i'm just going to go
alphabetically
department of agriculture
um
markets and food has asked for 180 000
for
their building at the eastern states
exposition
it's going to go quickly
see none then i would
without objection i will say that
we agree that that should stay in
the capital budget as as
okay
second
what
fishing game
um
what is that amount
four million six hundred fifteen
thousand dollars for the powder mill
fish hatchery i will say that one of the
members is very interested in that
uh representative newton and i have also
received several phone calls at home
about the need to do that this is
fishing game
so i open that
particular project
up to
okay so i will without objection
we will not discuss that
further today
and
suggest that we leave that in the
capital budget as it is
um
it's going much quicker um
judicial branch
mr chairman are up for just a second
sure
um
this is obviously representative mills
i'm i'm trying to keep track of this for
so that we don't have to go all over so
if we go a little bit slowly i'm going
to write down all the ones that we're uh
in agreement with
and um
just just keep track of it for future
reference
and uh i think the only place we'll
start will probably get into some
trouble is when we're going into
something like uh you know uh
health and human services where they've
got a huge huge
that's let's do them one at a time
that's it and and that's well these so
far have been like single things under
the agency that's the only thing that
they're doing and plus there was no
um
apparent discussion
or or disagreement with these
as we were um
going forward
with the hearings from
from all of them
which is why i wanted to discuss them
today
um
your hands still up david no i'm
lowering it thank you and muting myself
barry
you know i just want to say i mean i
want to do a general comment about
software being a capital
item or not being a capital item but in
this particular case i think this is a
this is a particularly important project
and one that
is a sort of it's not just an update of
existing things it's a radical change in
procedures so
hey
which one uh
the e chord
e chord right i thought that's the only
one i do and i i have and i think
several of us on the the committee have
shared that concern
over the uh
several um
biennia
about the amount of hardware and
but without an ability to put it into
the operating budget without busting
that budget um we've had to to do some
of it um
with
capital um
we tried trying to do it with five or
ten year bonds that just the treasurer
so any questions or comments about um
the continuation for funding of
new hampshire e court under judicial
branch which is 1.4 million dollars
representative evil the lawyer speaks
well i mean i just think this is a
continuation of a process that we
started you know several years ago and
um
they've spoken very highly of it that
it's very effective it's become even
more obvious how good this is because of
covid
and i um
i think it would be folly to uh
shut it down now i think we just need to
keep the progress going so i would be in
favor of keeping it in
yes mr thank you mr chairman
just echo
representative eagle says
i'm not a big fan of the
software being the capital budget but it
is what it is so
and
it needs to be done and it's been
and it has it
tv about
remote arraignments and all the rest
it's all been part of this what we're
doing with this so
um
it has been helpful representative jack
yeah so everyone's aware they have lapse
extensions from the three previous
times that we've given money that we're
going to carry forward and they're going
to pool it all and continue on
okay thank you
barry
just a quick addition this is one
one case and then maybe maybe true for
other software cases too but they you
know it's allowed the court to save a
lot of money
in terms of personnel
and
in terms of what you know with the
clients and and other people that
participate in the court system from
outside
save a lot of time and money as well so
i mean there's there's a good payoff
here as well as being you know
getting with them i
i totally agree as if you've
ever had to deal with the court as a
non-lawyer trying to find out what forms
or where to file you know the ecord is
making it more accessible to our
citizens as we go forward
so we are in agreement to
not change or reduce 1.4 million for new
hampshire e court
at this point and just
that will stay in in house bill 25 as is
see no disagreement
liquor commission
computer software uh credit card point
of service
for one million dollars there was
this is bond's other
um
and i will make a comment that that 1
million from the liquor commission is
the least amount i've seen at hb 25
for at least 15 years
because usually they're asking for new
buildings and the rest representative
mills
yeah i just want to go on record saying
one thing i i don't mind the fact that
we're bonding the million dollars once
again this is coming strictly out of
liquor commission
uh bonding authority anyway so it is
their money but this is at least the
third biennium we have seen this same
item for computer software for up for
point of sales for credit cards and
at what point do they ever think this is
going to end there's only so many credit
cards out there how much can they
any
any ideas
at all
i wish you to ask that question when the
director was there um yeah i i thought
about it well too late but i guess it's
something um
it's it's a little awkward this year not
having all the the books spread out in
front of us and all of last year's
figures to look at you sometimes can't
get to the the figures in a in a timely
manner but i do remember noticing that
wow this is at least
three bienniums now we've given them
money to upgrade a point of sale
marty
yeah uh if i remember the testimony
correctly they did address the fact that
they had a problem with their vendor and
they had to re-bid it and is that the
project they had to do that on
it's the only project they pitched so
yes okay
thank you that's that's
like i said i'm fine with the money i'm
fine with the amount it's just something
i'm going to make a close note of for
two years from now
if if any of us are still here
melissa you had your hand up
okay
so we're in agreement to to leave the
liquor commission
alone
all right
um
police standards and training
um there were two projects
um the air conditioner replacements and
range ventilation and filtration upgrade
between them
they were 1.325
million dollars
of generally funded bonds
discussion on
seeing none is anybody opposed to
leaving this in house bill 25 as
seeing none that
will stay
and the reason as i said earlier i'm
doing this is because in our next work
sessions after we've had a chance to
think through some of the other stuff
we're going to have longer discussions
on people who have asked for more money
so i want to get the ones that we're not
going to argue about done
um
veterans home
um two projects generally funded uh up
master plan update and parking lot
repairs and improvements for a total of
1.460 million dollars generally funded
bonds
any questions about that
comments
see none
i would
accept that is that is also one that
we're not going to
have to discuss
um in the future
now surprisingly uh i added one this
morning
on the university system
since they didn't
did not come in and ask for anything
other than what
was in the governor's proposal the 15
million dollars
i don't want to reopen that whole
uh
discussion we always have about what to
give to the university system and i
would suggest that since we did promise
that
while not appropriating it two years ago
it was part of a larger plan
that we would fund their projects over
three biennium um just to split up the
cost
that we leave that at 15 million
for the university system for the
projects that they showed at the three
campuses
uh marty
yeah just so everyone's not confused uh
this appropriation is in is in section
on line 16 of page seven
that's on the
spreadsheet the compare sheet
and as i said this morning
that does count towards
our overall um
generally funded
um
what's the word anyways what what will
be generally funded in house bill 25
this time even though it was promised
just just a clarification i just want to
um let the committee know that the the
university's um appropriation was
actually
um
done in 2019 so that was approved in
2019 in the 29th capital budget
so when you look at your bonds
authorized in section 5 of house bill 25
that number won't show up there because
that's only going to show from section 1
and 2 of the house bill 25 before you
and that is why um just to make sure
everybody knew
that the governor was still in support
of this 15 million appropriation you've
got you have the section 11 in the um
capital budget is introduced
but as it has been discussed so far this
does count
or will count against the the total
bonding that does occur in 22 and 23.
so i just wanted to make that clear
because if you're trying to add that and
you're looking at section 5 of the
capital budget
yeah it says 109.7 million dollars
you're not going to add the 15 to that
because it's already been appropriated
that's only going to be the new
but it does count against what
the treasurer looks at as
um
bonding
new bonding within
uh this biennium
that's absolutely correct
this bill could fail you could itl house
bill 25 but the appropriation for the 15
million dollars to unh
is still
allowed because it was approved by the
but what i'm trying to get at is we
don't have 15 million dollars to play
with for for other projects
no you don't
okay
thank you mr chairman i just wanted to
say that i think is it
i'm committing to this for
the three bienniums
that it would be inappropriate not to
well i i tend to agree i've
been working on these multiple
um biennium projects for the university
since 2001.
we have always lived up to our
obligation that we've committed to
as we go went forward
because the caveat on all of these as
they said earlier today was
we give them a certain amount of money
based on what the estimate is
we don't give them any more if it goes
over they pick up the uh
the additional cost from some source
um so
from our our perspective as as
public works and highways that works out
well may not work out well for the
budget of
the university system but
so we are in agreement that
that
for uh
university system
stays at
15 million
with no in increases or decreases
um
i don't know does anybody want to tackle
one or more of the
additional i don't i have not looked at
um for example admin services
corrections or hhs hhs
but
we also don't have
in front of us what if any monies
marty and his crew will be able to find
with the lapse
extensions
i don't think we're going to find
millions this time around
but if we do it would be nice
uh david mills
uh yes mr chair i was just wondering
whether or not before we even start
attacking everything uh uh department at
a time if we'd like to take a couple of
smaller ones
such as a department of safety
uh for 750 000 and just
just agree to that without considering
any add-ons or anything else that
they've already asked for if we just
want to prove some of the things that
have been asked for and the governor is
okay
just to lighten up the workload for the
future
i must have missed that um
safety did not ask for anything more did
they
i i don't know i don't have that in
front of me but i do know that this is a
is an amount we could probably agree on
for right now
for this particular
budget item if they ask for you know 25
000 to fix a sewer cover or something we
can take that up separate when we decide
to take uh add-ons
but these are just existing requests
make your make your pitch
that that's it i don't know whether they
have an add-on or not but i'd like to
see if we would we have any problem uh
putting forth seven hundred and fifty
thousand dollars of bond it
our general funds for the operations
center
marty
i was i i was just going to respond to
what do we know about the lapses uh the
agencies have been a little slow this
year
uh getting back to us so i don't have
all the information yet the one big
number i was able to find was a million
dollars but it's liquor funds so it
doesn't help us
yeah that's true now the other thing i'd
like to see is there were quite a few
agencies
that had quite a long list of
things that didn't get funded
and it just points out that we really
could use some more bonding authority
which really points out that we could
use some more unrestricted revenue to
use in the denominator
we also have bad discussion for ways and
means but we don't have it this time but
it it
it's sort of a a ticking time bomb that
there's all this deferred stuff that
people seem like they need and it's not
getting funded
and david i just went through their
presentation from safety somehow i
missed that in my my making my list they
did not ask for anything else
other than the 750
000.
so
anybody else have questions mark
thank you uh john
um hasn't it historically been when we
go through the lapse monies
that a lot of that money
has been repurposed for projects and
uh possibly projects that they'd like to
do as opposed to
pulling much of that money out and using
it for something different am i wrong um
we have habitually taken it as
money
that the committee can use
if it is within the same department fine
but if we see a higher priority
we've used it for that
so it really is
the state's money not the agency's money
so we can have that discussion if we
find it
um
so
that's that's kind of where we've left
it in the past
okay
mike you abbott
yes thank you mr chairman i did
the other thing i just like to uh
second what representative mills said
before but um
the other thing is that i don't
have any problem with the department of
safety's request
i would agree
no
martin
uh thank you uh can mr shea explain
sections 12 and 13
uh repurposing department of safety how
that was a request
that the department of safety made
during the governor's phase
originally it was in the draft of house
bill 2
and through discussions it was felt that
would be better placed in house bill 25
because that's typically where you find
that repurposing language and what
they're asking to do is repurpose some
highway funds from two projects and some
general funds from two projects for
their um
the aviation hangar that they've been
but that that's how it ended up in there
the department of safety made the
request as they were building the
um
house bill 2 and house bill 25 during
okay
um
we'll have to talk about that is
separate from their new appropriation
though correct
that's correct
okay
so when
when we get
um
marty's um report back we can discuss
what we're doing with with all the
collapse extensions and
changes and make sure the committee
totally knows
what all of these are you you have your
okay
um
one other thing i think
i think we could probably agree on
is the
department of transportation
generally funded
uh portion
for the the matches for
aviation
um
and
uh
public bus and
and facilities
um which is 1.724
uh million dollars which leverages well
over
um 27 million dollars of uh federal
funds
uh for for these projects
john claudia
uh yes mr chairman i totally concur with
your sentiments i urge that we i have no
problem with the department of
transportation's requests under federal
and general funds and we're getting a
lot of federal money for just one about
1.7 million in change so i totally agree
with that proposal and support and i i
think and i was trying to pin him down
but i couldn't that why i said
um
well north of the 27 million that's
listed
currently is
um there is a match
that is and for
the public transit and bus
um
that 250 k
is is going to be matched for
um
several million dollars as well so
i think it's worthwhile to do that it
a lot of our constituents scattered
dennis
dennis thompson
unmute sorry i'm sorry miss
chairman i'm having brought in
i'm having bandwidth issues but
i had one question about the the
aviation budget i saw her in there that
they're looking to repave
at the milan airport
and uh i just want to make sure that
that's going to be coordinated with the
national guard's
effort to build a new facility at that
airport
um
we can
ask
and i think that it would um
but
we haven't got to whether we're going to
fund the the request from the
national guard or not and we'll take
that at some point
um but now all of those
projects um tend to get coordinated
um
just so that we're not uh paving
something and then
um digging a ditch across it to put a
pipe down
no and i understand that i'm just
curious if uh
with the national guard project being
the size that it is
if this project on the highway part of
it is even going to get done in this
biennium
um there is if i remember looking at
their
their pitch for the um
the money for the aviation
um there is a priority list
which is probably larger than the money
that they are going to be getting
um
so
they they have the ability to move
within the license there move from one
to the other if something's not ready
they go to another one
um
and that's true of a lot of these
projects like that where
they may have a priority list under
um
a line item that if for either
permitting environmental study or
whatever there's something that they
can't
get to
they go to to another one i mean
especially true as everybody on this
committee should know of highways and
building uh
things like that
marty yeah um
as an initial matter the the way that
the aip funding works is it's 90 federal
five percent state which is what we're
appropriating now and five percent local
match
as to the timing of the projects it's
very similar to the way the corps of
engineers works on the port the faa
works on the airports and it's they
decide
when they're going to do the project and
we have to be ready
with the 5 match at the time they decide
to start the project so that's why we
and so yes that money
tends to stay around until the faa
decides to use it and it is flexed
as to what project it's used on and they
don't always ask for it because they
have
leftover money
uh where the faa hasn't gotten around to
annie
okay so
um
harry no negative comment david oh no no
i was moving on to the next one i didn't
know you were finishing up on this one i
just want to make sure that nobody has
objections
to the department of transportation
generally funded portion so that we
don't have to drag that back up again in
another work session
although there is plenty of opportunity
when we get
working on the actual amendment to have
any further discussion on any of these
or we may hear something different at
the public area
all right david
uh then then i would just i want to go
back to one other the department of
education that we didn't touch on
and only for what they've asked not for
any of the add-ons but i'd like to see
if we would approve the total it's 560
for two different projects the
generation installation at walker
building and the pre-engineering
technology i wonder if we could just
sign off on that
without considering any other
they did have one other request
and we did ask them for some additional
information
so we will have to discuss the
department of education again but i
think that we can
at least talk about agreeing to
[Music]
these two items which
total 300 000 generally funded portions
any comments actually they think they're
560 i'm sorry you're right you're right
general fund of course i'm right you're
always right i forgot you're always
right
okay david uh
any anybody have problems with
those two items
but we will have to
at least we did ask him since town
meeting was yesterday i have no idea
what whitefield did or where they are
um on a cte i don't know how we would
fit it
in all honesty into this budget even if
they did
um
we may have to
give some serious consideration other
things if we want to do that
um
but
representative newman what do you
so
on mu yes thank you i'm on muting
um could you just repeat which which of
those two items
it is we're talking about
for education that was the
pre-engineering
pre-engineering technology
and the generator installation at the
walker building
which is um
federally funded in part
so
um
any other comments about those couple
items
right like i said again we're going to
have to
[Music]
look at
the department again
at our next work session
on their additional requests
and
see where we think we're going to be
going because as we
add or subtract
um
it's not while not quite a zero-sum game
it's getting close to that
this time around
um it's just a fact of life
um
any others that we want to try to
do
today
mr chair
yes
the only one that jumps out on me that
we could we could do with very little
discussion is under the community
college system and i know they have
additional requests but the current
request that has been already approved
by the governor
for 2 million 550 000
for the
engineering technology renovation
um
i think that
there is no discussion shouldn't be any
of this real discussion on that one
since that is something that we promised
them two years ago
but we're still going to need to discuss
whether or not we need to give them
anything additional for critical
maintenance or any of the rest
but i think that um
from my from my own personal point of
view
um we should
um go ahead and say that the 2.55
million
that was there
from previous
[Music]
so i don't have a problem with that
mike edgar
uh yeah thanks john um
i was
going through my papers here and trying
to see what i saw last night but uh
on the community colleges with the
second part of the uh
the plot that supposedly had been
approved uh are kind of like
conceptually approved uh
3.3 million
that we talked about it before we're
also going to include the mcc uh science
lab
and it's not included this time the
governor didn't do it we kind of said
before that we were going to approve it
so i wanted to bring that one up
okay
um
i'd have to i have not looked at that
today
what is the ncc engineering versus what
you're talking about
uh this is a science lab it was the
second part of what we supposedly were
had conceptually approved before
um renovation of a science lab it was
it's a separate one it was
it was like a two-part thing we
supposedly said we would fund in the you
know next next time and i was trying to
find out where it was in here i saw it
last night and maybe uh mr shea uh
who knows uh
where that is or
but i wanted to bring that one up anyway
i know and also dude like you mentioned
you have the
like some life and safety stuff that
it'd be nice to be able to talk about i
don't know if we can with the money we
got
well and that's why i didn't bring
um
this one's going to take a lot more
discussion
because everything that they're asking
for is in the
if i remember correctly in the millions
um
which is um
going to be difficult to do
and we having we got to the hard ones
like corrections and
and the rest and maybe
when we get to
the emergency funds and what's already
what's still there and what they're
asking for
and the rest to see if we can't
find some money that way which we have
done in the past
um but those are all longer discussions
and i don't want to get too far ahead of
with everything
before we actually have the public
hearing
because there may be some impact
on that mr shea you have your hand
raised
uh just to follow up on representative
edgar's comment in looking at the 2019
capital budget there was a note related
to the
3.3 million dollars for the ncc
engineering technology renovation
but there wasn't um a note related to
and that's what the 2.5 million um that
you see in the current budget is
reflective of
that's where the general court said if
they can find the money going forward
essentially they would give it to them
in this upcoming capital budget
and that's the challenge finding the
money
yes thank you mr chairman
and the other thing i i just needs to be
done another day because
um i wasn't really happy with the
response to
the statewide student information system
and data warehouse that was proposed in
and that all of that
as i've said several times now today is
going to be our challenge of what do we
win all out change
or whatever to stay within
what we can reasonably bond
this biennium
and
it's harder
than it looks folks it's harder than it
looks
uh karen
yeah it's always a puzzle that's for
sure
so i'm i'm struggling a little bit
because i always uh kind of know what
the debt ratio is for what the what the
um
treasurer has i've been trying to find
it in here like what the debt ratio is
for 120 then what it is for what the
governor uh is proposing and then
not that we would ever dream of going
above what the governor has but maybe
130 what that would be i mean i think
that would be really helpful just to
give us some kind of framework
um
so that was one thought
uh and then
so i don't know if it's possible when
she comes in if we could just talk a
little bit uh more about that
um i'm looking what
i'm going to suggest that you send her
an email
and ask her
that's absolutely fine i mean
and and at 120 125 130 i'm gonna i'm
sure she's going to
come back of it's 6.11 or 6.1
it's not going to change the debt ratio
appreciably
but what it is going to change is
my ability to sell it
to
the house of representatives
um
remember we have to get it through
not just this committee but the floor of
the house and it's going to be
an interesting couple of days in
uh april since every committee now is go
as the same reporting date for every
bill
i mean there you got that nifty rule
change and everything and here we are
um i i just find that you know we've
done that in the past i find that a
really a good framework so we sort of
know what we're about i remember the
last
two years ago when i asked well what
does it do if it goes from
i think it was up a couple percentage
point right it took it up like 30
million dollars right which was a
non-starter
um even though it stays within the debt
affordability
uh ratios um you still have to sell it
to the house and the finance because
every dollar we take out
um
for debt service is money that uh can't
go to other programs as everybody should
be aware it's a
balancing act between all of those
things
so so then just um along those lines
we all there's just a staggering amount
of this budget that is going to i.t
and
i remember last year we did work with
doit i think we paired their request a
little bit because they were going to be
implementing their concept over time
and
i don't know if it's help i mean maybe
we could have asked each individual
agency this but i don't know if it's
helpful to talk to commissioner goulet
again and see if he thinks that there's
any
room to sort of stretch this out a
little bit i mean
i don't have an it's got to be 25 of our
budget or so for these huge i.t requests
and i just i mean they're so huge it's
and if they're do you know what i'm
saying
i do i'm also willing to call him if
that's helpful it would be you know i'm
sure he can talk about his own agency
which is only six million but just
looking at um
well hhs for instance hhs but all of the
those or almost all of them are
uh
us and 50 federal
um so if we cut those we cut the federal
right delay the pro
i mean
we can ask them to come back and
justify all of them but
they were in there and they talked about
each of them before we do that i would
ask that each member
go through the presentation from hhs and
see whether or not
it makes sense
and
yeah just so
i think hhs is a tough case because
they're such a huge portion of what
they're doing is federally funded anyway
but since since doit has in beds and all
the different agencies
um you know maybe he would have some
some thought on that i
we just have so little wiggle room this
year that
i thought that might be a source it
might be
um
we can ask him to come back
or i can just give him a call if he says
if you would if
if he's comfortable with
um coming back on the afternoon of the
16th he's more than welcome to talk a
little bit about
the overall i.t picture i mean i just
think for the committee that might be
helpful
i i think so too
um
it's no
secret to those who've been on the
committee for a while i've always had
problems with
uh the amount and it seems to be
increasing every biennium
on what we're buying for software
marty jack yeah the other thing about
hhs we need to keep in mind is
they were
the federal
they have a lot of compliance
requirements and they were saying we're
getting fined because we haven't done
this so the longer we delay it
the more we get fined
yeah and you know there could be there
could be issues of losing funding and
that type of thing so
we need we need to really keep that in
mind
thank you
uh
barry
yes thank you i i just want to add that
i went through i flagged about 11
million dollars worth of yt stuff
i wanted to talk about and all of that's
outside of hhs recognizing that
but if we drop it then the projects
aren't going to get done
and that that's the fact of life those
projects are not at this point in time
are not going to get put into the
operating budget
um
work
a little
with with less money than even the
governor thought he had
although he's never mind i'm not gonna
get into that whole thing but um
we shall we shall see mr shay
yeah i just wanted to remind the uh
committee that if you look at the doit
presentation
on page seven of their documents yeah
they list all the um i.t projects
contained in house 25. it's about 40
million if i remember right uh 35
general funds 107 million when you
include the other funds yeah they also
provide in there the agency priority
when it was requested um you know which
agency the project title and then the
requested amount and the breakout by
fund sources
so
they put that in there just to
make the committee aware that they have
been involved with the various projects
but again just page seven of their
documentation may help you yeah
uh thank you and i think that
at our next work session if everybody
could look at that because
this is gonna be a continuing
question john cloutier yes thank you mr
chairman um i just was looking over the
2019 capital budget and
looking at it we actually cut 2 million
from the department of informational
technology a two million dollar cut that
the senate went along with so we have
debated this issue before and i struggle
with this too
but i think we may be ought to look at
it and but there is a precedent because
we did it two years ago cut their budget
if i remember correctly on that one uh
karen ebel was the one who carried the
water with oit
to spread it out over
uh more than one biennium and now we're
into the this year yep that's that's
exactly right and that's why i i raised
it um as i said i think hhs and
compliance related issues that's that's
different but
anyway he i he the commissioner is
incredibly helpful and knowledgeable
about these things so
i think he could answer just about
anything
thank you
yeah
i just want to go over one last thing
and then i i with your permission i will
read out to everybody what we've all
agreed on that we've already agreed on
okay that's the only thing i didn't get
a definitive answer on
is the community college i know we're
going to discuss
some of their new requests but did we
agree
to sign off on their current
governor approved request for 2.55
million dollars for the
technology renovation
and i did not see any objections when
when i raised that
um okay i think we are in agreement with
that one
with the with the caveat that
we really do need to
to
look at that whole system
and their requests um
a little bit more detail
then if you'd like mr chair i'd be will
i'll be happy to go through uh the uh
budget comparison report for everybody
so that they can update their figures
do it
all right on the hp capital budget
compare report on page one
agriculture
markets and food we've agreed to the
hundred and eighty thousand dollars
eastern states exposition building
on page two under the department of
education
we've agreed to the two hundred and
sixty thousand two hundred and yeah two
hundred sixty thousand federal money and
three hundred thousand dollar bonded
money for two items
also on page two
fish and game
powder mill fish hatchery we've agreed
on page four under judicial
branch
we've agreed to 1.4 million on the new
hampshire e e-court
on the liquor commission we've agreed to
one million dollars for their credit
and on the bottom of that page four
we've agreed to under police standards
and training
both the air conditioning replacements
and the range ventilation
uh in the amounts of 475
page five
under
veterans home we've agreed to the eighty
thousand dollars for the master plan
update
and one point
and
million for the parking lot repairs and
improvements
under the community college we've agreed
to
2.55 million
under the engineering technology
renovation
under the department of safety we've
agreed to these emergency operations
center technology budget of 750 thousand
dollars
under department of transit
transportation under aeronautics rail
enter transfer
transit i'm sorry we've agreed to the
generally funded portion of 1.724
million
22.
to um
nothing on page six and on the final
page seven we've agreed under the
university of new hampshire
that 15 million dollars for their three
construction
projects
that's what i've got out of this
discussion
disagreement with that yes um
seeing none
um
do we want to take a stab at
is everybody ready to do that or would
you rather have some time to go back and
look
mr chair if i can weigh in i think
environmental services is something that
has always treated as
as something that we just about have to
do unless we've got some good recourse
as to not doing it
and i think they uh of all the
departments come through pretty much
with a this is something that we can't
delay anymore this is something that we
have to get done or this is one of those
projects that we're going to start
facing fines on so i'm just weighing and
i have no problem
with the uh 27 million 113
that we are
obligated to come up with under general
funds
and the total for the
uh entire agency subtotal
i'm trying to look through here real
quick as i'm listening to
david
representative mcconkey
i am i would uh i don't know about the
additional question i have to flip books
for that
um i'm in agreement with representative
mills the only the only one that i might
possibly have a follow-up question is
the one-stop it system upgrade
which is five what's that five million
but other than that i and i and i'm not
i'm not overly not in favor of that i
just i thought there was some questions
asked about that
but in general i'm in favor
representative edgar michael
oh thanks sean um
do i agree with uh what's been said so
far as far as all the requests but there
is the additional information they sent
us which had three items on it
and in particular
i'm interested in the coastal flooding
model
um
i'm involved in different uh coastal
marine commissions and things like that
and uh
and also get to see the the floods about
every month down here
um
but to have a model like that would be
helpful for the state and a lot of
agencies and um and that is for
uh they say in a range of 350 000 i
think you'll find a lot of
support for that
uh karen
yeah uh actually the same is what what
mark said um i'm i'm fine with the rest
of it but if we were going to talk
anymore to um
commissioner goulet it might be
interesting to check in with him just
generally about the one-stop system um
so
yeah
okay
uh barry
you know i agree with what mark and
karen said that was i had the same
questions
okay
yes thank you mr chairman
i'm not going to echo it but the same
thing that theory is karen and mark said
okay so
what i'm hearing
with no objections so far
is that what they have asked for
in
house bill 25
we're okay with
but if we can find money
uh mike edgar would like to at least add
one project to them
well i think we ought to consider taking
that extra money for the
project mike mentioned out of the one
stop i thought that were a little bit
loosey-goosey about
what they needed for one stop and that
seemed a little more flexible than some
of the other
um
get an answer too and i'm not sure
because i'm looking through my notes and
the rest and
it
doesn't say a lot about uh
and i haven't gone back and re-read the
project summaries and the rest
but if we were to do that i don't know
what it would do to the overall
um one-stop uh upgrade if we took you
know 300 whatever thousand out of that
well mr chair i think this was the one
where the governor actually um
appropriated less than what they had
requested for for the clean water and
dam repair projects
um that's true it was but um i don't
remember what they said about that but
they could it's it's a match
it's it's to match um if you give them
more they can match more um
but at some point it's um
i don't want to um
on the federal matches
um
if there's
i think he just did a a quick
you know gave it even numbers rather
so
so we're in
i okay um then let's not have put a pin
in any of these at this point
um on des
um mark you had something
um i was i was just gonna say that you
know i i'd move that we would uh just
remove the five million
uh for further discussion and you know
and approve uh 22
113 500 agree on those
and then we'll look uh when we have that
discussion and we look to add on
projects if there's money uh
then we'll we'll bring up uh michael's
project and talk about it then
if that if that would be helpful if you
want to leave the whole thing open for
discussion
i can go but
you know we can agree on on those light
items on page two
of the compare sheet
um
it is line 49
and 53
that we would agree to
um and then we have a further discussion
on line 52 which is the system upgrade
and then talk about that but that would
solve some of our problems of
um trying to get some things done in
future work sessions
mr chair could could somebody remind us
i'm sure that mike anger has it in front
of them
well i have it too i have my books in
front of me uh well i have a lot of
but um
so we would have to find the money for
that
but i don't want to arbitrarily take it
out of that 5 million
line item
without knowing what that would do to
so we shall see
any
thing else that i i'm not sure that we
can
um
go through because i really do want to
see what what comes out of friday
and i want to
have everybody go back through
especially
admin services corrections
hhs
to to see
what
you think about that
um
and
we shall go from there
um natural
i don't remember if they asked for
anything else or not
they had quite a few additional projects
then let's just hold off on them so that
we can discuss all of that
um
i think we got a lot done i mean
none of these decisions are final as
i've said several times
nothing is final till we have the exact
session but having these
discussions
and seeing where the committee is and
working towards a consensus
makes it easier as we go forward
um in the in the rest mr shay
just before you end today i just wanted
to make sure um is there anybody you
would like me to invite to the
work session at one o'clock on the 16th
that the committee might want to hear
from in terms of
the treasurer if possible
yep
and
oit
do you want employment security to talk
about their one stop uh not employment
security
yeah
all right are you flying with just the
oit okay yeah um
if they were on at the sa yeah
okay
because i would like to know if we took
half a million dollars from that what
does it do to that project
i think i know what their answer is but
we shall ask them
no i just wanted to
to make it a little bit easier for the
committee try to have the right people
available for you oh yeah
any other
um
from any of the committee is are there
any other agencies that you would like
to have there
on the afternoon
16. um representative clutter here just
a question i'm sorry
the military affairs and veterans
services department are we all set with
that i mean it's just only one of them
they came in with several different
things that they would like to do and
changes and i'd like to have that
discussion
um
separate as as an entity
so that we can get it all done at once
okay were you thinking of having them
come back on wednesday you know for the
work i think they gave us everything
that they wanted to do
okay
unless you want to hear from them again
at this point okay i think hopefully
we'll have enough information but as of
now i i just maybe we should sift it
through but it's they're not asking for
very much in general funds it's mainly
federal funds yeah but some changes
around it okay all right i wasn't sure
mark
thank you um
thank you john
uh page two under correct uh corrections
uh line 38
we had interest in
talking about that uh rebuild the sewer
line and grinder pump which i think was
for an off-site building across the
street
and
whether they were going to build a new
system
or whether to pump it into the uh
and i believe into the
town uh sewer
or city server i i think we asked them
for more information to follow up on
that
and i don't know if anybody's received
i have not
um
so mr shea if you could ask corrections
to come back as well
yep i'll do that
okay
um
your hands still up john include you no
no i'm all second thanks anyway um
yes yes thank you mr chairman the only
thing i wanted to
ask is that i still have some questions
about the
natural cultural resources on the
mult canon
proposal
um
that is not
within the capital budget
and i don't see us being able to fund
that this time but we can ask them to
come back and explain it in more detail
if you want
no that's fine
good
bye kendra
uh thanks john um
yeah as far as the corrections go i i
believe that the rebuild sewer line and
grinder is the infamous one we've been
looking at for a bunch of years
and it the the one that was referenced
was an additional one that they wanted
us to consider which was
new septic system
whether to put a septic system in or to
a line out to the road i just want to
mention that that's that's right
at night
that's right and i i think that there's
enough confusion at least in my own mind
about what we're talking about there
that it might not be bad to spend five
or ten minutes with them to get it done
karen
thank you um i guess i just wanted to
kind of clarify what i'm doing and what
mr shea is doing so if mr shay uh is
going to communicate with the treasurer
then he could ask her to do the 120 125
and 130 that okay
so is that okay and then as far as doit
um i just wanted to clarify
i i actually i personally don't have a
question on or a problem what they're
requesting i mean this the so that's on
page three
um there's cyber security on line 85 is
the other piece that they
sort of gave back to us last year um
and i don't have a problem with their
budget so if
chris if you're gonna ask uh
commissioner goulet to come in it's not
so much to defend his budget it's just
to talk to us globally about all these
issues and and get his thoughts and he
can we can about one stop but then we'll
also have des there so we can ask them a
little bit more i mean does that make
sense
so so my understanding for inviting doi
is that there was a number of computer
projects
throughout the capital budget and there
was a number of questions about
scalability for some of those projects
right so i assume that's why we would
bring them back
to
individual questions
but if you want to do it that that's
that would be good no i can invite them
in and let them know that's what we want
to do one thing with the department of
information technology they did have one
ask related to their capital budget but
it was a footnote the same type of
footnote you saw
in the 2019 budget and it just allows
them to
take their three capital appropriations
money around between the three
to
accommodate when they have issues that
but not an increase in any of the values
that they were requesting
but yeah he did ask to have that in
there again
and i don't think we have any problems
with allowing them to move
um
if cyber security becomes more important
than than the others then letting them
move some around
we might look at language about um
who oversees that but that's a whole
different ballgame
all right hi um
just i guess just a heads up
under military affairs and veterans
services
back uh february 16th we all got or at
least it was included there was an e
uh note that we got from uh general
michael mccoloitis and and
i printed it out on pink paper um anyway
i think that is a good um
i think that's a good reference to uh
refer to that 415 000 and
his other needs there i'm just throwing
that out for people to just refer back
to it when we get to that department
and that's why i said i didn't want to
take it up at this point so that we
could all have a chance to examine yeah
i agree thank you because
again i'll i'll say that every time that
we come up with another
400 500 600 000
it
keeps edging our bottom line up so
we have to take all of this the entire
budget into account
as we look at individual
um
agencies because
it does matter it and it matters
for those retained bills it matters for
agency requests
and
we really do need to
keep the the bigger picture in mind
because i know that once you get into an
agency
you go
yes they really do need that
um but what do you give up
and i know that
the returning members on the committee
anybody who's dealt with budgets in the
past
understand the need to um
step back every once in a while and say
is there anything else that anybody
seeing none
um
i thought i heard somebody um
thank you all for coming i thank you all
for coming back um
please um
the public hearing as i said several
times
will be
next tuesday the 16th
at 9 30 in the morning
it's a hybrid meeting
i know at least two people have
contacted me about wanting to testify so
there will be public input on
some or all of the projects
so please
be attentive to what our constituents
have to say about this
and then we will go into another work
session
try to get as much done as we can
and then we'll have about a week's break
um to get any additional answers or
information before we come back for
hopefully a final work
session
um before getting an amendment done
um
and marty
will be running the uh the lapse
extension meeting
on friday
everyone is welcome to go to it and
attend
um
but he is the chairman of that
anything else for me
john clutier
uh yes uh john um so next week we're
going to have the public hearing and
followed by a work session so that's
going to be the only
uh meeting of the committee that we'll
have next week is that correct that is
correct
we'll anticipate the following week when
we would be 23rd
23rd and 25th
23rd and 25th for our planning okay and
hopefully we would the 23rd we'd come in
and finalize everything and get the
amendment and hopefully be able
to get the amendment done by
afternoon at
noon of the
20th 23rd probably
um hopefully
to get that done so
then it's turnaround time at um
legislative services
because with the
deadlines having been changed
every committee
is
doing amendments
so we will be competing for time um with
the drafters for an amendment
um because they all have to be done by
the first of
april
turned in
by the first of april
which means the exact session has to be
before that
okay i just wanted to get some idea give
us some idea of how much longer was how
many more meetings were you expect we're
going to take if
we cannot if we cannot finish because of
either work or the amendment isn't done
we will meet the morning of the 29th
which is a monday for an exact session
okay that's your fallback okay good
would be just that um
all right my desire is to finish it the
25th but okay all right thank you i
don't always get what i desire
yeah
any other questions
um i think i'm all set at the moment but
if members
think of the next few days that you
might need for the discussion on the
16th please send me an email and i'll
try to you know find it or locate it or
get the right people there
and i want to thank the lba staff
they are the ones who have set up
this zoo meeting in the next couple
otherwise would still be arguing about a
room for this week with
the speaker's office
so thank you very much
and with that
um
this
work session of public works and
highways committee is adjourned
and thank you all for